Und damit ist es mal wieder soweit. Am letzten Donnerstag im Monat gibt es das Chaos Radio Imblemon auf ritz.de und es geht heute um Hardware-Hacking, es geht heute um Schippschleiferei, es geht um Dinge, die uns folgende Personen im Näheren erklären werden. Hallo und herzlich willkommen Starbuck. Hallo und herzlich willkommen Dmitry. Hallo und herzlich willkommen Thorsten.
Grafel.
So, wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen, um über Hardware-Hacking zu reden und das hat einen ganz bestimmten Grund, weil wenn wir normalerweise über technische Systeme reden, also selbst hier im Chaosradio, dann reden wir meistens über die großen Maschinen vor uns am Schreibtisch oder in unseren Hosentaschen, aber es gibt ja tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr Technik und die ist überall. In Autos, in, was hab ich gehört, Jalousien-Bedienungsgeräten. Garagentoröffner, Türschlösser, weiß der Geier was und das sind natürlich auch alles Dinge, mit denen kann man, es ist Spaß haben, das richtige Wort.
Unfug treiben.
Unfug treiben. Genau. Und wir wollen heute mal genauer auseinandersetzen, warum man das macht, wie man das macht und was da bis jetzt auch schon so passiert ist. Wie immer gilt, wenn ihr währenddessen Verständnisfragen habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen, 0331 70 97 110 oder wenn ihr selber einen wirklich coolen Hardware-Hack angerichtet habt, könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen, 0331 70 97 110. Wie heißt das denn, wenn man es nicht anrichtet? Was? Was? Ja, wer dazwischen quark, muss das auch erklären. Ja, bitte?
Zusammenhackt.
Und damit das so noch ein bisschen nicht nur so abstrakt ist, ja Hardware ist ja überall, sondern ein bisschen konkret, würde ich gerne, dass jeder von euch mal ein kleines Beispiel erzählt, was man denn so für Unfug anstellen kann.
Ich will nicht anfangen. Ich muss erst mal das Pad aufmachen.
Nein, ja, Unfug. Ich meine, du hast ja ein gutes Beispiel genannt. Ich meine Autos zum Beispiel. Die Jalousie. Oder die Jalousie, ja. Gut, dann ist die Jalousie auf deines Licht drin. Das kann schlimm sein für die Leute, die drin sind. Ja, nee, aber Auto. Jeder hat ein Auto zu Hause und kennt das Problem, dass das Auto besser zu sein sollte, wenn es irgendwo in einer belebten Stadt steht. Und ja, mit diesen Funkschlüsseln lässt sich schon eine Menge Unfug treiben. Jeder kennt vielleicht auch diese kleinen Gadgets, die mal als TV-Begann populär geworden sind, mit denen man irgendwie sämtliche Fernseher ausschalten kann. Das wäre ja schon auch ziemlicher Unfug, wenn man Autoschlüsse hätte, mit denen man in der Straße alle Autos aufmachen kann. Oder zumindest könnten einige Leute damit viel Geld verdienen. Und das ist halt schon so ein Target aus der realen Welt, wo man sich ganz gut vorstellen kann, dass sich da Hacker dran setzen, um herauszufinden, wie diese Schlüsse funktionieren. Und wie man eben vielleicht auch dafür sorgen kann, dass man damit fremde Autos aufmachen kann.
Hört sich spannend an. Dmitry hat vor der Saison voller Begeisterung von Druckerpatronen erzählt. Was hat das damit auf sich?
Genau, also was viele Leute unterschätzen ist eigentlich, dass in jedem...
Was viele Leute unterschätzen ist, dass sie nicht dicht genug ans Mikrofon gehen, wenn sie reinsprechen. Du musst wirklich sagen, siehst du dieses schwarze Ding? Ich habe es jetzt davor erklärt, du musst es sprich hinein.
Mein erstes Chaosradio.
Ja, ich muss schnell lernen. Ist es jetzt besser so?
Ne, du musst wirklich rangehen.
Also, das Beispiel, was wir vorhin besprochen haben, war eigentlich Druckerpatronen. Und viele Leute uns schätzen, dass heutzutage in jedem Druckerpatrone, also und auch Tonerpatrone, eigentlich eine Smartkarte drinsteckt, die sich gegenüber den Druckern authentifiziert. Also womit dann garantiert wird, dass man die 80 Euro, die eine Laser-Druckerpatrone heutzutage kostet, so eine Tonerpatrone, dass das eben der Kunde bezahlt hat, um überhaupt diese Patrone in seinen Drucker stecken zu dürfen.
Also das heißt, die Druckerpatrone redet mit dem Drucker und sagt, hier, ich bin total echt von Firma XY. Und viele Dritthersteller beißen sich die Finger ab, um sowas selber herzustellen. Starbuck, dein Lieblings-Hardware-Hack?
Ich wähle das Thema Ausweisdokumente.
Ausweisdokumente, aha.
Also im einfachsten Fall oder im kompliziertesten Fall, im interessantesten Fall kann man sich einen Chip, also die neuen E-Pässe und E-Personalausweise, haben natürlich einen Chip drin. Und diese Chips sollen natürlich die Eindeutigkeit dieses Dokuments bzw. die Verbindung vom Dokument zum Inhaber repräsentieren. Und wenn man jetzt in der Lage ist, diesen Chip zu klonen, beziehungsweise so zu verändern, dass man mit einem gefälschten Ausweis den Anschein erweckt, dass es ein echtes Personalausweis-Dokument ist, kann man natürlich auch viel Unsinn anstellen.
So, das alles sind Beispiele für Hardware-Hacks. Und normalerweise, wenn man Hacker kennt, es gibt ja auch sozusagen extra Vortragsreihen Hacker in Movies, da sieht man Leute vor einem Bildschirm an einer Tastatur sitzen und wirre Zeichen fliegen über den Bildschirm. Und als ich vorhin versucht habe zu erfahren, was ist denn eigentlich Hardware-Hacking, hat Dmitry gesagt, das ist etwas, wo man nicht an der Tastatur sitzen kann. Könnt ihr es vielleicht noch ein bisschen genauer beschreiben, was das eigentlich ist?
Also für mich ist es sehr oft ein Fall, wo man wirklich seine eigene Hardware dafür entwickeln muss, um überhaupt einen Anschluss oder sich an das Zielgerät anschließen zu können. Also du musst in irgendeiner Art und Weise den Anschluss selber herstellen. Und oft halte ich das irgendwie selber Platin-Edzen oder bauen. Und ja, halt auch ein bisschen die Programmierung, die dahinter steckt, um das Ganze anzusteuern.
Also die Werkzeuge selber herstellen. Also wie man das ja bei Software-Sicherheits- und Software-Hacks ja auch tut, da baut man sich dann irgendwie auch ein Stück Software, was eine bestimmte Schwachstelle ausnutzt oder irgendetwas analysiert. So ist das bei der Hardware halt auch. Und ja, man kann tatsächlich auch sich mit Hardware-Hacking beschäftigen, ohne jetzt gleich seine eigenen Geräte zu bauen, die genutzt werden als Werkzeug. Es gibt schon eine ganze Reihe an Werkzeugen, die bereits verfügbar sind, die man sich kaufen kann oder nachbauen kann. Aber ja, also das geht schon so ein bisschen in die Richtung. Man muss nicht immer alles gleich selber komplett bauen. Es gibt halt auch genügend Werkzeugkoffer, die man benutzen kann.
Also im einfachsten Fall tatsächlich, dass man es in die Hand nehmen kann. Also wenn man Software-Hacking macht, diese Software kann man halt nicht irgendwie anfassen. Man zählt Tastatur, um mit der Software zu interagieren. Aber halt, beim Hardware-Hacking ist halt tatsächlich irgendwas, was man gerade aufmacht, was man irgendwie in die Hand nehmen kann und damit dann Dinge tut.
Okay, also ich sage mal, es ist wahrscheinlich falsch, aber Lötgold.
Zum Beispiel auch ein Lötgold.
Tatsächlich, okay. Wuhu, Beispiel war richtig. Also jetzt wissen wir schon ganz grob, worum es geht. Also Druckerpatronen, Autotürschlösser oder Personalausweise und noch viele andere Sachen, die uns sozusagen im Alltag umgeben. Und wir wissen auch, dass es was damit zu tun hat, dass man Dinge in die Hand nehmen muss. Und jetzt wollen wir euch mitnehmen auf eine Reise durch das Hardware-Hacking. Und Thorsten hat mir erklärt, man fängt am besten bei Schlössern an.
Warum? Erklärt ist gut. Das war einfach ein gutes Beispiel, wo man irgendwie anfangen kann, weil so ein Türschloss hat jeder zu Hause, kennt jeder, ist jedem vertraut und ist halt ein Stück Metall, ein Stück Hardware, ist halt wenig Elektronik drin gewesen. Damals, heute gibt es das auch noch mit Elektronik, aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema. Aber so ein Schloss und der dazugehörige Schlüssel sind ja, ist ja ein Schutzmechanismus, der als Hardware dafür sorgen soll, dass deine Wohnung oder dein Haus sicher ist gegen unberechtigte Eindringlinge. Das heißt, du kommst, du hast halt einen Schlüssel, den hat nur der Besitzer und möglichst kein anderer. Und dann hast du das Schloss, das hängt draußen, das ist draußen an der Tür und ist quasi öffentlich. Und in diesem Schloss verborgen sind halt geheime Muster, die der Schlüssel halt erfüllen muss. Dann kannst du als regulärer Benutzer deinen Schlüssel in dieses Schloss stecken und das ganze Ding umdrehen und dann ist das Schloss auf und damit die Tür. Und nun gibt es aber hier einfach auch schon den Fall, und das hat halt mit Computern und so Digitaltechnik überhaupt wenig zu tun, dass es dann irgendwann mal Leute gab, die sich gedacht haben, wie können wir diesen Schutzmechanismus in Form eines Stück Metalls, eines Schlosses aushebeln, um ohne dieses Schloss oder die Tür kaputt zu machen, irgendwie diese Tür trotzdem zu öffnen. Und da kommen wir dann halt in die Richtung Lockpicking. Und das, denke ich, sollte jedem einleuchten. Und ich denke, das ist ein Niveau, wo man halt anfangen kann, über Hardware-Hacking zu sprechen. Das hat nichts mit Digitaltechnik und Elektronik an sich zu tun, aber es ist vielleicht so ein ganz gutes Beispiel, um sich ein bisschen vertraut zu machen, dass man eben Dinge in die Hand nehmen muss, Werkzeuge in die Hand nehmen muss, um sich dann an diesem Stück Hardware zu schaffen zu machen, um bestimmte Eigenschaften und Schwächen auszunutzen, mechanisch, um dazu zum Erfolg zu kommen. Und das wäre ganz sicher irgendwie so ein Einstieg überhaupt von Hardware-Hacking zu sprechen. Heutzutage gibt es auch noch Schlösser, die auch noch elektronische Komponenten mit drin haben. Das wäre dann etwas, wo ich persönlich, wo mein Interesse geweckt wird, weil ich mich ja doch eher für die digitale Geschichte interessiere bei dem Thema. Und ja, da wird einfach nochmal eine weitere Komponente hinzugefügt, die dafür sorgt, dass dieser mechanische Schutzmechanismus ergänzt wird durch einen mathematischen Mechanismus, eben durch irgendwelche Krypto-Algorithmen, die dafür sorgen, oder die sicherstellen sollen, dass der Schlüssel, der da gerade reingesteckt wird, auch wirklich zu diesem Schloss gehört, dass der eben authentisch ist. Also da gibt es dann eben bestimmte Protokolle, die dann dafür sorgen, dass der Schlüssel sich gegenüber des Schlosses authentifiziert. Und wie gesagt, das wäre halt eher der Punkt, wo ich ansetzen würde und sagen würde, das interessiert mich.
Aber um bei Beispiel zu bleiben, solange das Schloss noch mechanisch ist, nimmt es halt einen Dietrich. Also im Prinzip kann man sagen, ein kompliziert gebogenes Stück Draht. Und jetzt hat das Ding noch Elektronik drin. Was sind dann die Werkzeuge, mit denen man da rangeht?
Ja, dann muss man halt schauen. Also dann fängt wirklich langwierige Arbeit an. Da muss man gucken, ob man...
Also im Zweifelsfall hilft auch ein langer Stück Draht. Normalerweise haben die halt irgendwie Motoren drin, die dann irgendwelche Riegel wegschieben. Und der einfachste Fall von Hardwerking von elektronischen Schlössern ist, dass man halt zwei Nadel nimmt und auf den Motor kontaktiert und dann von außen Strom anlegt und sich der Motor an dreht. Und dann funktioniert das auch so. Das ist auch ein Hack, ist ein bisschen sehr einfacher.
Absolut, ja, ja.
Aber eigentlich irgendwie eine sehr lustige Angelegenheit. Also vor allem einfach, bevor man dann irgendwie anfängt, sich die Chips anzugucken und zu gucken, ob da irgendwelche Schwachstellen drin implementiert werden.
Das ist halt einfach sehr viel komplizierter, wenn man halt versuchen möchte im... So ein Schlüssel hat dann halt auch ein Chip drauf. Dann läuft dann halt irgendeine Software oder irgendeine Logik drauf. Und dann müsste man halt wirklich im nächsten Schritt schauen, dass man da Fehler in der Implementierung oder im Konzept findet oder in irgendeinem Crypto.
Also, wir waren gerade dabei bei der sehr einfachen Variante des Hardware-Hacks, nämlich, ich weiß, es gibt da ganz viel komplizierte Elektronik, aber zum Schluss hängt ein ganz einfacher Motor dran und den leg ich einfach Strom an, bang, geht die Tür auf. So, jetzt hab ich schon verstanden, die andere Ebene, wo wir vielleicht so nach 11 hinwollen, ist, man guckt sich Chips von innen an, da gibt es Unterschied zwischen Logik und Programm und so, das kann man alles später noch machen. Gibt's noch so Zwischenschritte?
Ja, da wollte ich drei Tieren auf. Du hast mich gestoppt.
Ich hab ihn gestoppt.
Du hast mich angeguckt, als du ihn gestoppt hast. Also, was ich gerade sagen wollte, ist, man kann natürlich auch die einfachste Möglichkeit, also du hast so Funkkommunikation zwischen dem Schloss und dem Schloss. Und was man halt im einfachsten Fall tun kann, ist, dass man sich dann nebensetzt mit einem Aufnahmegerät und die Funkkommunikation zwischen dem Schloss und dem Schloss mitschneidet. Und dann ist der, also während eines berechtigten Schließvergangs, dann ist derjenige, der gerade berechtigt diese Tür aufgemacht hat, irgendwie auf Toilette. Und dann nimmt man sich halt irgendwie sein Device und stellt statt Aufnahme auf Wiedergabe und spielt halt den gleichen Funkwellen wieder ein und kriegt das Schloss auch auf.
Jetzt muss ich mal nur fragen, ist das jetzt ein theoretisches Beispiel? Oder ist das was wirklich vorgekommen?
Das ist schon ziemlich praktisch und demonstriert einfach ein typisches Problem, wenn man eben Krypto-Protokolle implementiert, dass man nicht dafür sorgt, dass eben solche Replay-Attacken einfach auch verhindert werden.
Also Henrik, der irgendwie auch schon durchaus hier im Chaosradio war, hat vor ein paar Jahren auf einem Kongress mal einen sehr coolen Vortrag gehabt, wo er mit einem iPod und einem praktischen angesteckten Draht, der irgendwie als Mikrofon gedient hat, das aufgenommen und dann wieder eingespielt hat und somit die Tür in seiner Uni praktisch aufgemacht hat. Das war ein sehr, sehr cooles Video, gibt's da.
Okay, jetzt haben wir auch schon ein Fachwort gelernt. Replay-Attacken sind also, ich nehme irgendwelche Signale auf, spiele sie auf einem anderen Weg wieder aus und habe einen Mechanismus umgangen oder ausgelöst.
Genau. Okay, nächste Stufe. Die nächste Stufe ist dann die Relay-Attacke, wo man sich zwischen, also wieder so RFID, also du hast halt eine Funkkarte, die normalerweise mit der Tür kommuniziert. Hier ist es so, dass das halt nur auf sehr eng begrenzten Raum funktioniert. Das heißt, wenn die Karte an die Tür gehalten wird, funktioniert es. Wenn jetzt derjenige mit der Karte in der Mensa sitzt und du vor der Tür stehst und dein Kollege oder dein Mithacker auch in der Mensa ist, dann hält er ein Lesegerät an seine Karte. Du hältst ein Lesegerät, eine Kartensimulation an das Lesegerät vor der Tür. Du leitest praktisch die Daten von der Karte in der Mensa zu der Tür weiter und machst die Tür auf, ohne dass die Karte wirklich in der Nähe von der Tür ist.
Okay, das sind ja beides äußere Dinge. Nächstes Level dann? Also ich warte jetzt darauf, was es wirklich losgeht mit dem Hardware-Hacking. Dass man irgendwie Dinge aufmacht.
Es ist gerade mal 22 über 20.
Ja, pfff.
Grad saß es noch nach 11.
Also als nächstes käme jetzt Chips aufbasseln oder so.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Also das war jetzt so richtig die Kommunikation und...
Naja, ich dachte, dass jetzt kommen die ganzen Dinge.
Ich denke, wir wollten vor allen Dingen auch mal noch ein bisschen definieren, was Hardware-Hacking überhaupt ausmacht und wo es aufhört und anfängt. Also wir sind da, glaube ich... Ja, wir haben da einiges übersprungen auf unserer Listart.
Ich helse dich jetzt auch hier nicht als Protokoll.
Okay, ich mach den noch echter.
Die armen Leute vom Radio, die fragen sich, was machen die Leute da? Wir machen folgendes. Wir haben versucht, vor der Sendung so eine Art Konzept zu entwickeln. Und das Chaos Radio heißt ja nicht etwa Chaos Radio, weil es der Chaos Computer Club ist, sondern wegen dem, was ihr gerade hört. Und wir versuchen, das jetzt sagen, weiterzumachen. Also was ich sagen will, ist zu sagen, das sind jetzt Attacken, wo man quasi Dinge belauscht. Mehr oder weniger. Was gibt es denn dann noch? Und wo hört das dann auf, Hardworking zu sein? Wo geht es dann woanders hin?
Na, für mich hört das mit der Hardware auf, sobald man wirklich anfängt, sozusagen die Software auf dem Gerät zu analysieren, wo man nach irgendwelche logische Fehler sucht oder wo man dann nicht mehr den Signal sozusagen weitergibt. Man fängt wirklich an, die Software zu analysieren. Also es kann sein, dass das ein Teil der Software Open Source ist und dass man da versucht, klassisch sozusagen Fehler zu finden, wie beispielsweise bei Smartkarten oder PETV-Karten. In den ersten Generationen gab es da durchaus sehr viele Software-Bugs, wo man teilweise sozusagen nicht normale Nachrichten an die Karte schicken konnte und damit klassisch ein Buffer-Overflow. Also man hat klassische Fehlerarten ausgenutzt, die man auch von der Software kennt, die auch sozusagen im täglichen Leben genutzt werden, um dann Malware auf unseren Rechner zu installieren.
Und da kommen wir halt auch zu der Motivation, was überhaupt das Ziel ist von jemandem, der sich irgend so ein Gerät vornimmt. Denn die meisten Geräte oder Gadgets, über die wir ja reden, das sind ja im Grunde einfach kleine Mikrocontroller oder auch vielleicht komplexere Controller, wo ein Stück Software drauf läuft, eben irgendeine Firmware. Und ein Ziel oder eines der Hauptziele ist es ja, an diese Software oder an dieses Binary ranzukommen. Da kommt man normalerweise ja nicht ran. Eine Firma, die irgendwie einen Plastikrouter herstellt oder irgendein medizinisches Gerät oder irgendein Autoschlüssel, die gibt ja den Quellcode nicht raus, weil sie halt da ihr Intellectual Property schützen wollen, weil sie versuchen wollen, in Software-Algorithmen zu verstecken, die halt irgendwie irgendwas Besonderes implementieren. Und sie wollen natürlich verhindern, dass die Leute an den Quellcode oder auch an die Binary kommen, also sprich an die Firmware. Weil wenn man die Firmware erstmal hat, also es ist einfach Software, die läuft dann auf so einen kleinen Mikrocontroller, wie auf einem Computer ein Programm läuft. Und wenn man die Software hat, dann kann man sie halt analysieren und reverse-ingenieren und gucken, ob man in der Software irgendwelche Programmierfehler findet, wie Dmitry gerade sagte. Dann hat man eben auch den Fall, wenn man erst mal Zugriff auf dieses Binary hat und die Möglichkeit hat, aktiv nach Fehlern zu suchen, dann kann man diese Fehler auch ausnutzen, wenn man welche gefunden hat.
Ok, also Hardware-Hacking ist sozusagen dann der Weg, um Zugriff auf die Software zu erhalten, die auf so kleinen elektronischen Devices.
Ja, das ist eine Motivation. Also das gibt auch noch andere. Ich meine, wir haben auch Hardware, wo gar keine Software läuft, die ja so wirklich rein auf Logik basiert sind.
Also der Unterschied zwischen Programm und einer Logik, ist das sozusagen für Nichtprogramm überhaupt zu unterscheiden oder ist der Datenfluss dann nur weniger kompliziert?
Nach außen sieht es halt genauso gleich aus. Also entweder du hast halt wirklich eine Prozessorkarte oder einen Mikroprozessor, der halt Programmcode, also wie ein Contuber, irgendwie sein Programm abspielt, oder du hast halt tatsächlich eine Karte, die halt den Code selber in Hardware gegossen hat, also wo halt dann wieder kleine Transistoren irgendwie rumflippen und damit halt praktisch das tun, was normalerweise die Software tut. Also eigentlich ist es halt tatsächlich so ein Schritt. Früher gab es halt irgendwie Hardware-Karten, beziehungsweise die billigen und schnellen Sachen sind halt komplett in Hardware gegossen. Und heutzutage, beziehungsweise mit zunehmender Komplexität, nimmt man dann halt gerne Smartcards, Prozessorkarten, die halt eine Firmware haben, die man halt auch viel einfacher updaten kann, wo man halt viel mehr machen kann.
Also sagen, fürs bildliche Vorstellungsvermögen, ich will es nur abstrahieren, ist sozusagen, ist sozusagen Programme, die auf so Chips laufen, sind dort abgespeichert, aber man kann sich es wirklich wie beim Computer vorstellen, dass da quasi Textzeilen stehen, die nacheinander abgearbeitet werden und Logik in einem Chip, dann ist wirklich zu sagen, wenn man den Chip und den Mikroskop anguckt, dann gibt es da ganz, ganz, ganz viele kleine Leiterbahnen und jeder Einzelne ist ein Programmschritt und der ist auch nicht mehr veränderbar dann. Gut, wir haben jetzt tatsächlich schon eine Frage, eine Frage, die mir auch gekommen ist, und zwar Adrian, 21 aus Bernau. Hallo Adrian. Guten Tag, du hast eine Frage, ob man auch etwas anderes hacken kann.
Genau, ob man alles hacken kann, so wie Sky oder die ganzen WLAN-Boxen.
Die Verbindung ist so, dass ich nichts verstehe.
Ich habe nur Sky verstanden. Es geht um PTV.
Ich frage jetzt, ob man jetzt die neuen Sachen wie Sky und die WLAN-Boxen hacken kann.
Sky, also die PTV. Also Sat, meint der Anrufer, denke ich mal.
Okay, also die Verbindung ist so schlecht, Adrian. Vielen Dank für die Frage, aber es ist, glaube ich, besser, wenn du am Radio zuhörst, weil man versteht dich kaum. So Sky, PTV. Darüber wollte ich eigentlich nach den Nachrichten sprechen, also bleibt noch ein bisschen dran. Mir wurde vermittelt, dass er auch nach Geldautomaten gefragt hat, eigentlich fragen wollte. Also man hört ja immer von Geldautomaten-Hacks. Sind das tatsächlich dann auch Hardware-Hacks, die da verwendet werden?
Naja, ich denke, es gibt in so Geldautomaten auch Komponenten, die durchaus in diese Kategorie reingehören. Aber so ein Geldautomat besteht im Kern ja auch nur aus einem ganz normalen PC. Und wir haben uns vorhin schon ziemlich intensiv darüber unterhalten, wo eigentlich dieses sogenannte Hardware-Hacking aufhört. Das heißt, ist denn irgendwie so ein PC oder eben so ein Laptop, wie er hier bei mir vor der Nase liegt, ist das nicht auch noch Hardware? Und wenn ich das hacken will, kann ich das nicht auch irgendwie so als Hardware-Hacker tun? Oder habe ich, also ich vertrete da die Meinung, nein, dann die Hauptaufgabe von so einem typischen Rechner oder PC wird ja doch durch Software bestimmt. Ich kann da andere Betriebssysteme drauf spielen und dann verhalten die sich ja auch grundlegend anders. Und ich greife im Grunde nicht die Hardware an, sondern die Software. Natürlich gibt es in so einem Computer noch ganz viele andere Komponenten, kleine Mikrocontroller, die auch bestimmte Dinge tun, wie zum Beispiel eine Netzwerkkarte. Und da würde ich schon eher sagen, okay, das passt in die Kategorie Hardware-Hacks, wenn ich da irgendwas tun kann. Da gab es übrigens auch noch, kann ich nachher, erinnere mich dran, ein cooles Beispiel, wo so ein paar Leute eben so eine Ethernet-Karte eben auch gehackt haben und damit den ganzen Rechner kompromittieren konnten. Aber so ein Geldautomat besteht ja am Ende auch nur aus einem ganz normalen Computer, PC, wo irgendein Mainstream-Betriebssystem draufläuft und...
Du hast ja schon deutlich mehr Hardware-Komponenten. Ja, ja, da sind ganz viele... im Zweifelsfall auch wieder im elektronischen Schloss.
Keine Frage, aber ich meinte ja, so ein Geldautomat besteht im Kern aus so einem Computer, der ganz viele kleine Geräte steuert. Und diese einzelnen Geräte sind ja miteinander verbunden über bestimmte Busse. Und wenn ich in der Lage bin, an diese Busse heranzukommen, dann kann ich dort genau ansetzen und Unfug treiben und dann kann ich eben gucken, dass ich die Protokolle emuliere oder eben Replay-Attacken durchführe oder selbst versuche, dieses Protokoll zu analysieren, um meine eigenen Informationen...
Also wir stellen fest, dass die Künste fließend ist.
Ich will nur ganz kurz sagen, wenn Programmierer Busse sagen, abstrahent gesagt, sind es einfach Datenleitungen zwischen den verschiedenen Komponenten. Man nennt sie Busse, weil sie die Signale auf diesen Leitungen über eine bestimmte Art und Weise transportiert sind. Danke, Starbucks, dass du den Job, den ich hier mache, so gut. Jetzt frag ich mich gerade, ihr habt dieses schöne Beispiel erzählt vorhin mit der Seitenkanal-Attacke. Merken wir uns dieses Schlagwort für später oder machen wir das jetzt noch mit der Tastatur? Liebe Leute, die ihr Geldautomaten, liebe Leute, die ihr schon immer mal wissen wolltet, was man möglicherweise tun könnte, um Geldautomaten zu beobachten, merkt ihr das Schlagwort Seitenkanal-Attacke. Wir machen erst mal Nachrichten und danach geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio.
Letztes Jahr spielten sie ein ausverkauftes Hammer-Konzert im Astra. Und das, obwohl der Sänger total krank war. Wie geil sollen das erst diesen Sommer in der Zitadelle werden? Wenn der Topfit ist. Mittwoch, 20. Live und Open Air in der Zitadelle Spandau. Imagine Dragons im Sommer unter freiem Himmel und hoffentlich topfit. Aber wenn nicht, ist auch gut.
Die Ukraine hat den Internationalen Währungsfonds offiziell um Hilfe gebeten. Angeblich steht das Land kurz vor dem Bankrott. Der Finanzbedarf für die kommenden Jahre wird auf umgerechnet 35 Milliarden Euro geschätzt. Der gestürzte Präsident Janukovic will sich laut Medienberichten morgen auf einer Pressekonferenz äußern. Er hält sich offenbar in Russland auf. Bereits heute erklärt er, dass er seine Absetzung nicht akzeptiert. Der Prozess gegen den ehemaligen Bundespräsidenten Wulf und den mitangeklagten Filmproduzenten Gronewold ist mit Freisprüchen zu Ende gegangen. Das Gericht erklärte in seiner Urteilsbegründung, ein strafbares Verhalten habe beiden nicht nachgewiesen werden können. Wulf sagte, das Recht habe sich durchgesetzt. Laut Anklage hatte er sich bei möglichen Sponsoren für ein Filmprojekt eingesetzt, weil Gronewold einen Oktoberfestbesuch von Wulf zum Teil bezahlt hatte. Die Staatsanwaltschaft will in der kommenden Woche entscheiden, ob sie Revisionen einlegt. Nutzer des Internetkonzerns Yahoo! sind offenbar jahrelang vom britischen Geheimdienst GCHQ ausspielendet worden. Der Guardian berichtet, dass zwischen 2008 und 2010 wahllos Standbilder von Videochats mit der Webcam gespeichert wurden. Betroffen seien etwa 1, 8 Milliarden Nutzer. Der Geheimdienst habe danach versucht, die Personen per Gesichtserkennung zu identifizieren. Das stehen Unterlagen des Informanten Snowden. Eintracht Frankfurt ist in der Zwischenrunde der Fußball Europa League ausgeschieden. Gegen den FC Porto spielten die Hessen 3 zu 3 unentschieden. Aufgrund des Hinspiels ist Frankfurt damit aber trotzdem draußen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick 2 und in Steglitz 7 Grad. In Brück 2, Lübbenau 4, Prenzlau 6 und in Falkensee 8 Grad. In der Nacht ist es überall ziemlich wolkig, Regen ist aber die Ausnahme. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 4 bis 1 Grad plus. Morgen wird es dann wolkig, später lockert es etwas auf bei 8 bis 11 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin-Neukölln, die Niemetzstraße, ist zwischen Lahnstraße und Saale Straße in beiden Richtungen nach einem Unfall gesperrt und nach Brandenburg A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden zwischen Groß-Körres und Teupitz gibt's Gefahr durch ein kaputtes Auto auf der linken Spur. Ansonsten rollt's euch ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Kostenlos, jetzt in eurem Google Play und App Store. Die Fritz-App.
Fritz.
Heute Chaos Radio in Blemun und es geht um Hardware-Hacking, also nicht Programmcode irgendwie hinschreiben, sondern sich wirklich die Finger mehr oder weniger schmutzig machen. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon versucht zu erklären, ganz grob was das ist. Es hat was mit Schlössern zu tun, könnte man sagen. Und wir haben auch schon erfahren, wo die Grenzen dessen sind und was man damit alles anstellen kann. Hardware-Hacking ist tatsächlich sozusagen nichts, was man erst seit dem Neuesten macht, auch wenn es immer mehr Technik wird, die wir mit uns rumschleppen oder die in unseren Autos zum Beispiel drin ist, haben wir auch schon gehört. Das hat schon eine kleine Geschichte und die werden wir jetzt ein bisschen aufrollen. Zu Gast im Studio sind Thorsten, Dmitry und Starbuck. Hallo und herzlich willkommen nochmal. Und die Geschichte des Hardware-Hackings, eine Geschichte voller Missverständnisse, nein, wird oft verbunden mit Pay-TV-Karten. Ich wusste das ja lange überhaupt gar nicht, weil ich selber gar kein Fernseher habe, hatte. Aber anscheinend gibt es Karten für Bezahlfernsehen, die aus Hardware bestehen, und die kann man auch hacken. Wie macht man das, oder wie hat man das gemacht? Was war da los?
Also eigentlich ist das, erst sollte man vielleicht erklären, wozu man das überhaupt braucht. Und das kommt eigentlich aus der, also Pay-TV war zuerst, also heutzutage hat man irgendwie Tehome und alle diese Anbieter, die, also das ist sogenanntes IPTV. Also da wird für jeden einzelne Kunde eine separate sozusagen Stream übertragen. Und damit kann man diesen Benutzer gegenüber der sozusagen der Content-Anbieter identifizieren und dafür sorgen, dass wenn der Kunde bezahlt hat, schickt ihn wirklich der Content-Anbieter dieses Content.
Also man kann sagen, das ist wie so eine Art YouTube mit Login, und wenn du nicht Geld überwiesen hast, dann brichst du Login.
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Und so funktioniert eigentlich modernes Fernsehen, könnte man sagen, oder zumindest, das ist das, was man heutzutage viel verbreiteter ist. Aber die Geschichte ist eigentlich so, dass noch vor zehn Jahren war, und auch heutzutage gibt es das immer noch, vor allem in Landkreisen, wo nicht jeder VDSL zu Hause hat. Hat da gerade jemand Brandenburg gesagt? Na gut, in Potsdam haben sie ja wiederum T-Home-Fiber, nicht wahr? Aber jedenfalls, das was man da hat, ist eigentlich Satelliten. Über den Satelliten wird ein Fernseher Stream übertragen. Und es funktioniert so, dass über diese Funkstrecke werden alle Sender übertragen und sie werden einzeln, jeder Sender wird mit einem eigenen Schlüssel verschlüsselt. Und dann, was man tut, ist, man gibt jedem Kunde seine eigene PTV, eine PTV-Smartkarte, eine Karte, die man in seinen Receiver, also das Gerät, was unter dem Fernseher irgendwie steht, steckt man da seine PTV-Karte rein und wenn man bezahlt hat, kann man den Fernsehen dekodieren. Und es funktioniert so, dass die Schlüssel für den Receiver für die nächste sozusagen zehn Minuten auch übertragen werden über die gleiche Funkstrecke. Das heißt, man kann mit einer zehn Minuten Genauigkeit gucken ob jemand bezahlt hat oder nicht. Also alle zehn Minuten werden neue Schlüssel übertragen und wer nicht bezahlt hat, bekommt nicht die neue Schlüssel in eine Nachricht, die explizit für seine PTV-Karte verschlüsselt ist.
Das heißt sozusagen, wenn ich damals bezahlt habe oder wenn ich in Brandenburg lebe, heute noch, dann bekomme ich so eine Karte, die es meinem Gerät erlaubt, den verschlüsselten Fernsehstream zu entschlüsseln.
Ganz genau.
Und dann haben sich Leute gedacht, Mensch, das wäre voll geil, wenn man das umsonst machen könnte.
Und was da interessant zu beobachten ist, ist eigentlich, man hat nicht den Kanal zurück. Also man kann sich nicht regelmäßig wirklich gegenüber dem Content-Anbieter autotifizieren. Der Content-Anbieter kann aufhören, die Schlüsse für eine bestimmte Karte auszuliefern, aber der kann nicht überprüfen, dass mehr als ein Zuschauer sozusagen mit der gleichen Berechnung, mit dem gleichen Schlüssel das Fernsehen entschlüsselt hat. Das heißt, was da tatsächlich stattfindet und wo viele Leute sich sozusagen sehr reich geworden sind, ist, dass sie sozusagen Karten-Clones verkauft haben.
Also, so muss man sagen, noch mal eine Runde einfacher. Es ist quasi wie eine Eintrittskarte, aber der Einlasser hat nicht die Möglichkeit, nachzuprüfen, ob die Karte, die ich vorzeige, kopiert ist oder nicht.
Genau, es kann sein, dass die zehn Leute, die vor dir reingekommen sind, exakt die gleiche Karte hatten.
Und der ist einfach zu doof, sagen wir mal, um das zu erkennen. Er hat einfach nicht die Möglichkeit. Jetzt stelle ich mir aber vor, dass sozusagen so eine Smartcard, wo dann halt diese Karten, wo diese Chips drauf sind, dass man die nicht einfach in einen Fotokopierer legt.
Ganz genau, was da tatsächlich stattgefunden hat, ist ein bisschen das, was wir vorhin angesprochen haben. Also hauptsächlich läuft auf diesen Karten ein Programm ab, der ein proprietary, also einen unbekannten Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus sozusagen auswirrt, der eben die Nachrichten dieses Content Providers, also der Sender, ja, also dekodiert, also entschlüsselt und den entschlüsselten Stream dem Receiver zur Verfügung stellt.
Ja, aber wie passiert das sagen? Also das ist so eine kleine Plastikkarte, da ist ein Chip drauf.
Genau, also da ist ein Chip drauf und auf dem Chip läuft eigentlich eine Software ab. Das heißt, wenn man auf diese Software kommt, wenn man diesen Algorithmus kennt, dann kann man eigentlich ohne weiteres sozusagen kopieren oder zumindest ähnliche Karten bauen, die dem Receiver, also wie gesagt, der Receiver ist zum Beispiel die Setup-Box, die neben dem Fernseher steht, die dem Receiver vortäuscht, eine echte Karte zu sein.
Also emuliert, authentisch zu sein.
Also im Prinzip zu sagen, wird das Programm von diesem Chip runterkopiert und dann auf andere, aber nicht nur die Software, weil die Software ist ja an sich auf jeder Karte gleich, das ist nicht ausreichend, also muss man noch einen Schlüssel aus der Karte extrahieren, um mit dem Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus den Stream entschlüsseln zu können.
Und wie macht man das?
Ja, also...
Jetzt wird es echt interessant, ach nein! Aber wie geht dieses Hardware-Hacking an dieser Stelle vor sich?
Ja, also da sind sehr viele Techniken über die Zeit entwickelt worden. Also am Anfang waren es tatsächlich relativ einfache Angriffe, wie das man eigentlich... Also man hat nicht richtige Nachrichten an die Karte geguckt und geguckt, wie sie reagiert. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass viele Hersteller ganz am Anfang, sie haben gar nicht bedacht, dass Benutzer sozusagen die Schnittstelle, die die Karte bieten, missbrauchen können. Und da waren sehr viele, also bei den ersten Generationen von Karten, also die man immer noch teilweise zum Spielen auf Ebay und so weiter kaufen kann, sind gravierende Fehler drin, mit denen man eine Nachricht manipuliert, so dass sie eigentlich gar keine Nachricht mehr ist und an die Karte verschickt, also sozusagen über die Schnittstelle, mit der die Karte mit dem Receiver spricht, dass man damit schon Informationen aus der Karte auslesen kann.
Okay, also normalerweise nimmt man die Karte das Signal vom Fernsehsender entgegen, das sagt, hier ist ein verschlüsseltes Paket, da ist der Schlüssel, mach das mal, und dann schickt man dem quasi irgendwie Datenmüll, der auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise...
Nee, aber da passieren mehrere Dinge gleichzeitig. Also ich meine, die Schnittstelle, also man hat auf der Karte selber, hat man nicht irgendeine Verbindung zu der Satellinenschüssel, die bei einem draußen steht. Also auf der Karte ist wirklich eine Schnittstelle, also diese Kontakt-Schnittstelle, die man auch auf seiner sozusagen Bankkarte sieht, auf seiner EC-Karte, ist die gleiche Schnittstelle, ist standardisiert. Und auf der SIM-Karte ist es auch die gleiche Schnittstelle. Über diese Schnittstelle schickt man Nachrichten, die eigentlich sowas sagen wie, hey, ich habe gerade folgende Nachricht bekommen, da müsste der Schlüssel für mich drin sein, kannst du mir das entschlüsseln? Und wenn die Karte den passenden Schlüssel hat und den passenden Algorithmus darauf hat, kann sie den richtigen Schlüssel sozusagen dem Receiver geben, womit er denn den Content Stream entschlüsselt.
Aber wie, also das Hardware-Hacking stelle ich mir jetzt vor, dass das genau an dem Punkt passiert, dass man sozusagen diesen Chip mit Werkzeugen verbindet. Womit bastelt man da?
Ja, also das Beispiel da ist, man steckt es nicht mehr in das normale Gerät, wofür das gedacht ist, nämlich der Receiver, sondern man bastelt oder kauft, je nachdem, man also basteln hat man, kann man viele Probleme vermeiden, die man gegebenenfalls sonst hat. Aber man will eigentlich einen Smartcard-Reader selber nachbauen, um dann manipulierte Nachrichten an der Karte mit einer höheren Geschwindigkeit, mit einer höheren Wiederholrate zu schicken. Und da kann man wirklich, also bei den ersten Generationen von Smartcard ging das tatsächlich, dass man einfach irgendwelche Nachrichten geschickt hatte und irgendwann kann man bekommen, also solange man alles mitgeschnitten hat, was die Karte zurückgeliefert hat, hat man teilweise das komplette Speicher von der Karte ausgelesen. Das waren solche gravierende Fehler auf der Karte drauf.
Okay, das ist also im Prinzip wie zu einem Banktresor zu gehen und anzuklappen, sagen, hier gib mir mal deine Geheimzahl.
Ja, bitte schön, alles klar.
Da sind die Hersteller wahrscheinlich irgendwann hintergekommen, was ist dann passiert?
Also, die Hersteller haben sozusagen Quality Assurance eingeführt und haben angefangen, nach sowas zu gucken und da fangen man an, andere Arten von Minimalisationen zu machen. Also, da kommt man eigentlich auf auch Seitenkanalangriffe und vor allem, was sehr effektiv in der sozusagen in der 2. Generation von PTV-Karten war, war sogenannte Glitching Attacks. Glitching heißt, dass man entweder an der Versorgungsspannung manipuliert, also man schickt nicht mehr ungültige Nachrichten an der Karte oder nicht nur jedenfalls, sondern man manipuliert die Versorgungsspannung oder man manipuliert die Taktrate, also den Taktgeber, der zu der Karte geht.
Lass ich mal kurz ein einfaches Beispiel zum Glitching, also zu Power-Glitching machen. Sagen wir eine Bankkarte, du hast eine PIN-Eingabe und du hast einen Fehlbedingungszähler, der irgendwie mitzählt, wie häufig du schon die falsche PIN eingeben hast. Nach drei Mal ist halt vorbei. Was normalerweise der Fall ist, dass man für das Schreiben dieses Fehlbedingungszählers, also das ist halt in einem Eprom geschrieben, das heißt man braucht halt eine gewisse Spannung, um diesen Eprom zu schreiben. Für den Betrieb der Chipkarte selber braucht man aber eine Spannung, die ein bisschen geringer ist. Das heißt, wenn man die Spannung von außen kontrollieren kann, kann man die Spannung so hochsetzen, dass der Chip noch funktioniert, aber es nicht genug Spannung gibt, den Fehlbedingungszähler zu schreiben.
Also eigentlich so niedrig zusätzlich.
Man betreibt also praktisch den Chip in normalen Mode, fragt halt alle möglichen Pins ab und guckt, ob die Antwort korrekt ist. Im Hintergrund kann aber die Karte nicht den Fehlbedingungszähler hochschreiben und nach dreimal sagen, jetzt mache ich nicht mehr weiter. Das ist zum Beispiel ein ganz einfacher Fall von Power Glitching, wo man durch die Übernahme der Stromversorgung die normale Funktionalität der Karte beeinflussen kann.
Okay, und das hat man dann auch mit diesen Smart TV oder PTV-Karten gemacht. Und das hat auch funktioniert.
Ja, und das funktioniert. Das ist schon einer der Angriffe, die eigentlich auch immer noch funktionieren. Also ich würde sagen nicht bei Smart Karten. Einfach weil die Industrie, die hinter Smart Karten steckt, hat einfach so viel mit dieser Problematik zu tun, dass sie mittlerweile auf einem guten Weg sind, sich gegen sowas abzusichern. Aber man kann das immer noch, also ein schönes Beispiel sind teilweise die alle, also ein sehr gutes Beispiel sind die Lesegeräten, die man hauptsächlich in den USA sieht. Ich glaube die sind, also ich habe sie jedenfalls in Deutschland noch nicht gesehen, aber was man da hat, sind Kartenlesegeräte, die man einfach am iPhone anschließt. Also man sitzt beispielsweise in einer Bar oder in einem Restaurant und möchte zahlen und da wird über ein Mikrofon oder über diesen dämlichen Apple-Connector wird da irgendein anderes Gerät angeschlossen, die die Karte auslesen kann. Und auch diese, diese, diese, ja, Schnittstelle muss sich gegenüber dem Backend, also die ganze Server, die für die Abrechnung dafür da sind, damit das Geld wirklich vom Konto abgebucht wird, müssen sie sich authentifizieren. Und da, da das wiederum nicht besonders sichere Hardware ist, die in diesem Lesegerät ist, kann man auch da solche Glitching-Angriffe sehr effektiv ausnutzen, um dann wiederum die Schlüssel, die auf diesem Lesegerät sind, auszulesen und dann weitere Kopien davon zu machen.
Wow, das ist ganz witzig, weil diese Kreditkarten-Lesegeräte für Smartphones, die werden immer mal wieder in Deutschland in so Tech-Blocks vorgestellt, so die Zukunft des Bezahlens, alles super, dann kann jeder ein einzelner Händler werden. Und das sind also die Dinge, die man damit treiben kann. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich an dieser Stelle die Frage, ist das was, also bei den Pay-TV-Karten kann ich mir vorstellen, da gibt es einfach Leute, die sind daran interessiert, weil da ziemlich viel Geld hintersteckt, wenn der Pay-TV-Anbieter sagt, meine Karte kostet 40 Euro, und dann sagen sie, für 10 kriegt er eine schwarzkopierte. Dieses Angriff auf die Kreditkarten, da muss man dann schon konkret jemand haben. Wie einfach ist das denn? Also ist das was, das kann man schon machen, wenn man so ein bisschen Ahnung hat? Oder ist das so, da braucht man ein hochdekliniziertiges Reinraumlabor?
Also die Pay-TV-Angriffe kann man heutzutage auch nicht mehr machen, da braucht man auch schon wirklich ein Reinraumlabor. Also Pay-TV ist halt wirklich ein gutes Beispiel für so Hardwerken, also für Hersteller machen, also erhöhen die Sicherheit, Hacker kommen her, irgendwie versuchen die Sicherheit zu brechen. Das hat sich ja über die letzten 20, 30 Jahre hochgeschaukelt. Und von daher sind die Karten im Endeffekt irgendwie auch sehr sicher. Also was auch wieder zeigt, wo halt dieses irgendwie Katz-und-Maus-Spiel wirklich zur Sicherheit geführt hat, es wird sich halt in anderen Bereichen auch zeigen, wenn halt irgendwie bei den Kreditkarten erst mal genug Fraud, also Betrug, Betrug geben wird, dann werden dann wieder Hersteller auch kommen und sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal sicheres machen oder sichere Chipkarten mit einigen.
Aber eure Prophezeiung ist schon, es wird eine erste Generation geben und die ist dann auch gut angreifbar.
Das stimmt so, aber die Lösung bei Banken ist auch etwas anderes, nämlich, dass du nur 500 Euro von deinem Bankkonto am Tag abbuchen kannst.
Der nächste Punkt ist, dass eben bei diesen ganzen Bankgeschichten, da gibt es auch noch ganz andere Ansätze, wo man halt sehr viel bequemer ansetzen kann als Betrüger und als Hacker, um zum Geld und somit zum Erfolg zu kommen. Also da gibt es einfach, solange es einfach diese leichteren Wege gibt, weil eben irgendwelche Verfahren das besonders begünstigen, dass Betrug stattfinden kann, wird das genau passieren. Denn die Betrüger und die Hacker sind genauso faul und suchen sich, also die suchen sich halt den Weg des geringsten Widerstandes.
Also das ist ja immer so eine Frage zwischen Aufwand und Nutzen. Und wenn es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gibt, mit geringem Aufwand den gleichen Nutzen oder die gleichen Gewinn zu erzielen, dann wird natürlich irgendwie der als Erstes.
Wenn so ein Hersteller oder eben so ein User, also was weiß ich, wer der Bank sich für einen bestimmten Chip entscheidet und sagt, so wir nehmen halt manche Risiken in Kauf, dann tun die das, weil sie wägen halt ab. Sie machen eine Risikoanalyse und sie rechnen halt mit, was ich, zehn Betrugsfällen pro Zeiteinheit und sagen, solange das so diese Schwelle nicht überschreitet, können wir irgendwie eine Entschädigung zahlen und können irgendwie mit diesen Problemen arbeiten.
Also, wir machen sozusagen genug Umsatz, als dass das dann uns nicht wehtut, den Leuten, die es versenden.
Und die müssen einfach nur abwägen, ob sie jetzt irgendwie sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie vier Millionen auf dieses Problem werfen, dann können wir das vielleicht beheben. Aber vielleicht lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht, vier Millionen zu investieren, um irgendetwas Besonderes, Sicheres zu kaufen. Wenn sie wissen, dass sie für Schadensersatzforderungen vielleicht nur eine Million ausgeben müssen. Also das ist halt so eine völlig banale Rechnung am Ende. Und ähnlich kalkulieren halt auch die Angreifer. Die denken sich halt so, okay, wenn ich irgendwie jetzt 50.000 Euro in die Hand nehmen muss, um diesen Chip aufzumachen, um danach Bugs zu suchen, ist es vielleicht doch irgendwie ein bisschen Overkill, wenn ich im Grunde nur 1000 E-Mails verschicken muss, wo ich sage, ich bin der König von sonst wo und, also, verstehst du, das ist so...
Das ist aber ein Software-Angriff dann.
Das ist dann ein Software, klar. Also, kleine Kulturbildungsempfehlungen noch, wer dieses Prinzip mal nachvollziehen will, Banken nehmen Fehler im Kauf, guckt mal bitte Fight Club, da wird das auch, also dieses Prinzip wird das sehr schön beschrieben.
Genau, ja, mit der Versicherung, das ist ja das, die Banken versichern sich für diese Sonderfälle nochmal ab.
Genau, das könnt ihr auf jeden Fall mal gucken, Hausaufgabe bis zum nächsten Mal. So, was mir jetzt gerade auffällt, es gibt also auf diesen Cards halt, wird Hardware benutzt, im Prinzip ja, um eine Logik oder um Code zu verstecken. Und dann will man wieder darüber rankommen, indem man die Hardware irgendwie aufmacht. Wird das auch noch in anderen Gebieten benutzt?
Ja, aber ich meine, also Smartkarten für mich sind, also alle die Geräte, die wir am Anfang genannt haben, sind für mich Smartkarten. Also was viele Leute unterschätzen, ist, dass der, es kann sein, dass man sozusagen alles, was man in der Tasche hat, auf den Tisch packt und da hat man irgendwie seinen Xbox-Mikro-Controller und seine Bankkarte und seine Autoschlüssel. Seine Druckerpatrone. Genau, seine Druckerpatrone und alle diese Dinge werden den gleichen Chip innen drin haben, der auf der gleichen Architektur basiert ist und der nur, also es kann auch sein, dass das völlig identische Chips sind in all diesen Geräten. Also insofern, die Karten, also als Angreifer, das wird auch sehr häufig gemacht auf dem Schwarzmarkt, dass sie erst beispielsweise, also stellen sie oder sie finden heraus, dass der Chip, der in einem sehr lukrativen Ziel steckt, dass er ebenfalls das gleiche Chip ist wie in einer SIM-Karte. Dann kaufen sie sich ein paar hundert SIM-Karten im Internet, weil die kriegt man teilweise von Vodafone, konnte man auf jeden Fall bis vor kurzem einige SIM-Karten umsonst bestellen. Dann bestellt man sich diese Vodafone-SIM-Karten umsonst, schaut man sich den Chip da an, entwickelt seine Angriffe gegen diesen Chip und kann sie dann direkt auf der Druckerpatrone oder auf den elektronischen Personalausweis anwenden.
Auf der anderen Seite auch der andere Weg, wenn man... verdammt.
Und da war der Faden. Ich meine, ihr hättet es in der Vorbereitung auch erzählt, dass es die Tendenz gibt, bei Herstellern zu sagen, wir haben hier eine Information, ein Algorithmus, da wollen nur wir wissen, wie der funktioniert, das soll niemand wissen. Und wir machen den nicht richtig sicher, sondern wir verstecken den quasi in der Hardware.
Genau, also, aber ich meine, das ist an sich, also, wenn man ein Informatikstudium abgeschlossen hat, dann weiß man, dass es verschiedene Arten und Weisen gibt, um eine Berechnung sozusagen darzustellen. Das kann man als mathematische Funktion darstellen, das kann man als eine komplexe logische Funktion darstellen, das kann man dann als Programmiersprache darstellen. Also, es gibt äquivalente Darstellungen. Und was man in der Hardware Security, also vor allem in der Hochsicherheitsindustrie, beobachten kann, ist, dass die Hersteller zunehmend sich entscheiden, Teile der Software einfach in Hardware, also in eine Implementierung, in einer Hardware-Implementierung, also in Transistoren, zu gießen, um, weil sie damit glauben, dass keiner ohne enormen Mittel auf diese Algorithmen kommt.
Also dieses Ziel, was ich vorhin erwähnt hatte, dass es ja ein Ziel ist, an diese Firmware dran zu kommen, an dieses Binary, was die Software am Ende ausmacht. Die versuchen das eben auszuschließen, dass jemand, der Software Reverse Engineering betreibt, in der Lage ist, diese Algorithmen zu rekonstruieren anhand irgendwelcher Software-Komponenten.
Mach mich das mal ganz einfach. Du hast einen Speicher, wo denn der Software drin ist. Normalerweise ist die Software da drin unverschlüsselt, das heißt, wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, die Speicher auszulesen, hast du die Software, kannst du irgendwie weiter analysieren. Was sie heutzutage tun, ist, sie verschlüsseln die Software in dem Speicher drin. Das heißt, du hast auf dem Chip selber nochmal ein Memory Encryption-Decryption Unit, das heißt, du hast in Hardware gegossene Hardware-Algorithmen, also Krypto-Algorithmen, die die verschlüsselte Software aus dem Speicher auslesen, dann entschlüsseln und dann der CPU weitergeben zur Weiterverarbeitung. Das heißt, das nutzt dir nix mehr, den Speicher auszulesen, sondern du musst tatsächlich hinter der Encryption-Decryption Unit versuchen auszulesen, um den entschlüsselten Speicher zu haben. Oder du reverse-ingenierst, also auf Hardware-Level, auf Transistor-Level reverse-ingenierst, diesen Krypto-Algorithmus, dann kannst du wiederum den verschlüsselten Programmcode auslesen, um ihn dann in Software zu entwickeln.
Aber du kannst doch auch was zu Myfail sagen.
Das war jetzt nicht unbedingt einfacher, Möchel. An dieser Stelle will ich merken. Ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen. Normalerweise liegt der Programmcode in einem Baustein drin. Den kann ich auslesen, wenn er unverschlüsselt ist. Was du jetzt gesagt hast mit Encryption-Decryption Unit, es gibt also ein Chip, das besteht aus mehreren Teilen, nämlich der Speicher, wo das Programm drin liegt, das ist verschlüsselt. Und dann gibt es in Hardware gegossen, was wir vorhin besprochen hatten, also sagen, wirklich, da ist kein Programmiercode, sondern das ist wirklich, sagen, Leiterbahn für Leiterbahn in Hardware geätzt, in den Chip, wenn man so will. Und das entschlüsselt diesen Code. Und wenn man das analysiert, kommt man wieder an alles ran. Aber wie macht man dann genau diese Analyse?
Also.
Also, jetzt geht's los.
Also, wir reden davon, dass tatsächlich der Kryptoalgorithmus in Hardware gegossen ist. Das heißt, wenn man an den Kryptoalgorithmus rankommen will, also der ist unbekannt, das heißt, wenn du halt wissen willst, wie er funktioniert, dann musst du dir die Hardware angucken. In den einfachsten Fällen, oder wie man es normalerweise tut, dass man ätzt oder poliert tatsächlich jeden.
Nur, dass jetzt alle mitkommen. Wir reden jetzt, wenn Starbuck angucken sagt, dann meint der angucken. Also wir gucken jetzt, was in dem Chip drin ist.
Genau. Also wir reden tatsächlich von dem, was du von maltest, irgendwie die Verdrahtung zwischen den einzelnen Transistoren. Also das heißt, man poliert oder etzt einen jeden einzelnen, also ein Chip ist so aufgebaut, dass du halt unten die Logikelemente hast und die sind dann halt verdrahtet. Das heißt, irgendwie Flip-Flops, Transistoren, wie auch immer.
Also normalerweise, ihr kennt das, ein Chip ist ein 4G-gestaltiges Ding, da gucken so Beinchen raus. Und wenn man den aufmacht, dann sind halt da drin sozusagen ganz viele 1000 Millionen Drähte.
Leiterbahn. Also wie praktisch, wenn du einen Computer aufmachst, dann hast du irgendwie auch so eine Karte drinnen, wo halt irgendwie Leiterbahnen drauf sind und dann die interessanten Funktionen. Was du halt tust, ist tatsächlich, du polierst in jeden einzelnen Layer, also in jedem...
Also sind Schichten übereinander gelegen, sag ich.
Genau, die Schichten, die halt praktisch die, also die Leiterplatten heutzutage sind ja auch nicht nur irgendwie oben und unten, sondern du hast ja auch ganz viele Schichten in den Leiterplatten. Was du halt tatsächlich tust, ist halt wirklich jeden Layer die Einzelnen anpolieren, ein Bild davon machen und dann die Funktion, die drauf implementiert ist, also zu Reheursongenieren, also praktisch zu rekonstruieren.
Bilddicke, sprich ich nehme ein Stück Sandpapier, schleife den Chip auf, bis ich zur ersten Lage komme, fotografiere das und mache ich dann den 2-Layer. Okay, jetzt ist das wahrscheinlich kein wirkliches Sandpapier. Also wie macht man das wirklich? Gibt es dann irgendwie so kleine Maschinen, die das abtragen?
Das ist in der Tat, wer will tatsächlich Sandpapier mit feinerer Sandkörnung, also wir reden jetzt hier nicht von irgendwie Millimeterkorngrößen, sondern eher so Nanometer, aber im Endeffekt ist tatsächlich mehr oder weniger wirklich Sandpapier, was man irgendwie, wo man ein Chip rauflegt und dann irgendwie hin und her rubbelt, bis halt irgendwie die Schicht ab ist. Da macht man irgendwie auch nicht mit einer Kamera so ein Foto, sondern braucht ein Mikroskop oder im Zweifelsfall ein Raster-Elektronen-Mikroskop, um halt schon die ganz kleinen Strukturen auch noch sehen zu können. Und dann hat man halt tatsächlich die Transistoren, also die grundlegenden Verschaltungsträger des Krypto-Algorithmus und die Verschaltung drüber, also wie halt diese Transistoren miteinander verschaltet sind. Aus den Informationen kann man dann tatsächlich den Krypto-Algorithmus selber reverse-ingenieren. Das heißt, du guckst darauf, sagst irgendwie, normalerweise hast du halt eine Reihe von Flip-Flops, die halt einen Krypto-Algorithmus implementieren.
Flip-Flops sind Schaltelemente, die Dinge tun.
Du hast Transistoren, also die Verschaltung der Transistoren, die halt im Endeffekt den Krypto-Algorithmus implementieren. Was du halt jetzt tust, also normalerweise hast du, also wenn wir jetzt von einer RFID-Karte reden, also einer Zugangskarte, wo du halt irgendwie die Karte gegen die Tür, gegen das Lesegerät hältst, dann geht die Tür auf. Das heißt, die ist relativ langsam. Das heißt, du kannst halt irgendwie nur, irgendwie sagen wir, in einer Sekunde dreimal die Karte gegen die Tür halten und dir sagt, ob es jetzt richtig ist oder nicht. Wenn du aber den Krypto-Algorithmus aus der Karte extrahiert hast, kannst du den auf deinem Computer nachimplementieren und der kann es halt nicht nur dreimal die Sekunde machen, sondern 300 Millionen Mal die Sekunde. Und wo halt normalerweise du 100 Millionen Jahre brauchst, brauchst du dann halt nur noch ein paar Minuten oder ein paar Sekunden. Das heißt, du kannst halt den langen, dauernden Vorgang, das irgendwie alle Schlüssel ausprobieren, im Computer, in der Computersimulation, wenn du den Algorithmus hast, aus der Karte extrahiert, irgendwie in sehr kurzer Zeit machen.
Wir sind also jetzt schon beim Chip-Schleifen angekommen. Unglaublich. Wo sind wir eigentlich? Herzlich Willkommen in der zweiten Stunde des Chaos Radios im Blue Moon mit Thorsten.
Hallo.
Aha, Dmitry?
Starbuck? Drei Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs, die uns heute mal etwas über Hardware-Hacking erzählen. Hardware-Hacking ist das, wo man sozusagen nicht programmierend an der Tastatur sitzt, sondern wo man wirklich Dinge tut. Und wie wir gerade gelernt haben, man schleift tatsächlich Chips auf. Also Computerchips, die man so kennt, nimmt man ganz Feines an Papier und trägt die Lage für Lage ab und fotografiert die dann. Und kann dann daraus sozusagen erkennen, was da drin ist an Programmierung. Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, möglicherweise sind ja die Chip-Hersteller nicht ganz doof und sind auch auf die Idee gekommen. Möglicherweise will jemand unseren Chips abschleifen und dann irgendwie einfach gucken, was da drin ist. Gibt es da Gegenmaßnahmen oder ist das gerade jetzt der Stand der Dinge?
Na, das ist halt ein Angriff, der nur auf ganz spezielle Arten von Krypto-Algorithmen also wie jetzt diese unbekannten Krypto-Algorithmen, die du halt praktisch durch das Abschleifen rausfindest, wie der Chip funktioniert. Heutzutage benutzen sie halt in der Regel keine proprietären Krypto-Algorithmen, sondern halt bekannte Krypto-Algorithmen wie AES oder Triple Desk oder halt Prozessorkarten, wo halt die ganz interessante Stuff in der Software läuft und nicht mehr in der Hardware. Das heißt, da nutzt es halt nicht mehr viel, diese Hardware-Angriffe zu machen.
Wichtiges Ding, dass wir am Rand lernen. Wenn Krypto gut ist, dann darf man auch wissen, wie sie funktioniert. Wenn Krypto versteckt wird, ist es immer ein bisschen komisch.
Und man lässt das in solchen Fällen oft auch in Software einfach ablaufen.
Okay. Jetzt hast du doch aber auf dem Kongress, Dmitry, einen Vortrag gehalten, wo es genau darum ging, noch um neue Dinge, wie man Chips aufmachen kann. Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Ja, so kann man das sagen.
Ist dann halt eher der Weg, wie man an die Informationen rankommt, über die wir hier sprechen.
Was ja nicht uninteressant ist, wenn man über Hardware-Hacking spricht.
Nee, genau. Aber ich mache das ohne Sandpapier.
Warum das denn?
Weil wir eigentlich in der Uni ein sehr schönes Gerät haben, wo man einfach Gewichte drauflegt. Und alleine durch dieses bisschen Gewicht, was man da drauf gedreht hat, schleift er einfach eine Stunde oder so vor sich hin. Und dann ist der Chip gedünnt auf die, so wie man das gerne hätte.
Verstehe. Also da ist dann kein Sandpapier da drin?
Wir reden von was ganz anderem jetzt. Wir sind jetzt bei der Rückseite.
Genau.
Also was ich ja gerade beschrieben habe, ist tatsächlich der Angriff durch die Vorderseite. Also wo du halt durch die aktive, also du guckst von vorne drauf, also da wo halt die aktiven Sachen, wo die Leiterbahnen sind, wo die Transistoren sind, da guckst du drauf, was Dmitry jetzt gleich beschreiben wird, ist Angriff durch die Rückseite. Also durch den Silizium-Block, sich erstmal von hinten ran zu arbeiten.
Weil die Hersteller eben von der Vorderseite Schutzmechanismen eingebaut haben, die eben verhindern sollen, dass man einfach eben durch diese obere Seite an die entsprechenden interessanten Leitungen kommt, um eben die Daten aus dem Chip zu extrahieren.
Also bevor wir dahin kommen, müssen wir erstmal die Angriffsart sagen, und zwar ist das Micro-Probing. Also was ich ja gerade beschrieben habe, ist praktisch, wenn du halt nicht weißt, was auf dem Chip, also wie der Algorithmus aussieht, dann guckst du dir so den Algorithmus an. Was man tut, wenn du halt eine Smartcard hast, also wo ein Programmcode drauf ist, dann versuchst du halt diesen Programmcode aus dem Chip rauszuziehen. Das tut man normalerweise durch Micro-Probing. Das heißt, man nimmt sich ganz, ganz kleine Nadeln, die halt so ein paar Mikromedie da vorne sind, geht auf die Bus-Leitungen drauf und sagt an dem Chip, so jetzt liest doch mal hier irgendwie den Programmcode aus dem Speicher aus. Und da man halt irgendwie genau auf den Bus-Leitungen drauf ist, die halt den Speicher mit der CPU verbindet, kann man halt genau einmal was die CPU sieht, also den Programmcode sich einmal irgendwie mit rausnehmen.
Also man lauscht quasi.
Genau, aber zur Laufzeit sollte man an der Stelle noch erwähnen. Also das heißt, der Chip läuft ganz normal vor sich hin und man kommt als Angreifer und effektiv wirklich mit kleiner, ein Mikrometer breiter Nadel setzt man die auf dem Chip drauf, auf die interessante Leitungen und also schneidet sozusagen die Kommunikation mit.
Und hat dann praktisch den Programmcode ausgelesen.
Aha, okay, also sagen, was du erst beschrieben hast mit dem Sandpapier, ist es sagen, da läuft der Chip nicht, sondern man trägt den Schicht verschwindet ab und der ist dann auch kaputt. Und baut ihn an und danach ist er kaputt. So, dieses Probing ist im laufenden Betrieb, steche ich also Nadel in die Leitung und lausche dann, was für elektrische Pulse rauskommen und...
Aber das eine ist nicht ohne, also eigentlich als Angreifer macht man, den ersten Schritt, den man macht, ist schon, solche Bilder von dem Chip zu machen.
Man muss ja wissen, welche Leitung interessant ist. Dafür muss man diese ganze, muss man sämtliche Leitungen und Transistoren reverse-ingenieren und sich ganz genau anschauen, wo sind welche Funktionen implementiert auf dem Chip. Dass man später dann ganz genau die Koordinaten kennt, wo man eben mit seiner Nadel auch drauf muss, um mitzuschneiden, was da drüber gequatscht wird oder um eventuell selber irgendwas...
Das heißt, man macht erst eine Autopsie von einem Chip und dann macht man es am lebenden Objekt.
Genau.
Und dann kommen wir zu dem, was Thorsten da erwähnt hat. Also die Hersteller haben natürlich gesehen, mit von vorne, mit den Nadeln, auf die Busse irgendwie raufkontaktieren. Das ist ein gängiges Angriffsziel. Und so der nächste Schritt, also die nächste Gegenmaßnahme dagegen, ist, dass wir halt irgendwie auf die Oberseite dann so was wie Meshes oder Shields aufgebracht haben. Das heißt, sie haben aktive Elemente, die verhindern, dass du halt mit der Nadel von oben auf diese Busseleitungen raufkontaktierst.
Also wenn die dann kaputt, die müsste man dann kaputt machen für diesen Zweck und dann bilden sie sich ein, dass sie das ganz sicher auch bemerken, dass dieses Schutzschild zerstört wurde. Dann wird quasi, ja nicht, man kann nicht sagen, da wird ein Alarm ausgelöst, aber... Dann funktioniert der Chip halt so in der Form nicht mehr.
Genau, wird einfach das interessante Material gelöscht.
Also geht dann was kaputt oder wird dann so eine kleine Säureblase ausge-
Beim nächsten Mal hochfahren fangen sie tatsächlich an, sozusagen das komplette Speicher mit Nullen zu beschreiben. Also die vollständige Information auf dem Chip zu löschen.
Also auf jeden Fall für den Angreifer geht der Chip dann kaputt. Also du hast halt keine Chance mehr, dann irgendwie die sinnvollen Informationen rauszukriegen.
Aber ich meine, es gibt auch andere Sensoren, die man vielleicht nur damit der Hörer sieht oder hört, wie krass diese Gegenmaßnahmen sind. Also ein Beispiel ist, dass man sehr viele Lichtsensoren auf den Chips verbaut. Und das heißt, der Chip detektiert Licht. Und wenn es Licht detektiert, weiß es, dass man das Chip aufgemacht hatte. Und diese ganze Chipfläche ist versehen dann mit Lichtsensoren, die nur dafür da sind, zu detektieren, dass der Chip aufgemacht wurde.
Das heißt, das Package, dieses schwarze Epoxid-Blobbel, der außenrum ist. Das heißt normalerweise ist es dunkel in dem Chip. Wenn jetzt plötzlich Licht dran kommt, dann weiß der Chip, da hat jemand das Package aufgemacht, dass es doch garantiert angreift, dann lösche ich lieber den Sprecher.
Interessanterweise kann der Hacker einfach im dunkelten Proben das passiert tatsächlich nicht.
Es geht natürlich auch noch anders. Ich meine, diese Schutzmechanismen basieren am Ende ja auch nur wieder auf ein bisschen Logik. Das heißt, diese Sensoren oder diese Meshes, die liefern irgendwo einen Input, der ist dann eben 0 oder 1. Und wenn man halt vorher diesen ganzen Chip analysiert und jeden Layer auch sich ganz genau anschaut und weiß, man sieht ja dann auch, man findet, man sucht dann vielleicht erstmal auch nach dieser Logik, die diesen Schutzmechanismus implementiert. Und wenn man diese Logik dann auch ausschalten kann, dann kann einem das am Ende auch egal sein, ob man da irgendwas versteht.
Das Problem ist, normalerweise kann man es halt nicht ausschalten, weil man erst durch das Mesh durchgehen muss von vorne. Aber jetzt kommen wir tatsächlich zur Rückseite.
Genau.
Eine Frage noch sozusagen. Also A, das ist Interesse an den Chips und B, diese Sicherheitsmaßnahmen. Ist das jetzt bei allen Chips, die so überwägt sind? Also, keine Ahnung, der Prozessor an meinem Rechner, hat der sowas? Oder ist das wirklich Vorbehalt so ganz speziellen Chips?
Interessanterweise sind die alle sichersten Chips, die man auf dem Markt kaufen kann, diese blöde PTV-Karten, die man hat, die sind wesentlich sicherer, also die haben, wenn man die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen anschaut, dann haben die wesentlich mehr Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, als jeder Arm-System-on-Chip, der in seinem Smartphone ist oder sein Intel-Prozessor. Die haben da eigentlich gar keine Maßnahmen, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass der Chip viel zu hoch komplex ist, dass jemand sich sozusagen die Mühe geben würde, tatsächlich Transistor für Transistor da durchzugehen und die interessanten Informationen zu holen.
Und auch eigentlich viel zu uninteressant, weil tatsächlich 100% des interessanten Informationsgehalts kommt aus der Software, die auf dem Prozessor läuft.
Und die PTV-Branche hat schon sehr viel Geld verloren und die haben natürlich eine Motivation, da auch Research zu stellen.
Und wir müssen das ein bisschen zu quantifizieren, also ihr wisst, das eine, also ich meine, das sind so in den USA, ist das die 11. oder 12. Generation von PTV-Karten. Und alle Generationen zuvor wurden gehackt. Also das heißt, sie müssen 11-mal neue Chips entwickeln, bevor sie eins gefunden haben, was jetzt einige Jahre überlebt hatte.
Wie waren vorher so die Halbwert-Zeiten?
Ja, also da gab es schon sehr schlecht, also es gab verschiedene Hacks, ja. Also es gibt vielleicht nur, weil die PTV-Branche so eine lebendige Geschichte hatte, sollte man auch, also es gab auch diese Software-Bugs, da gab es, man kann die Karten tatsächlich über sozusagen die Funkverbindung, also über Satellit auch patchen. Beziehungsweise man kann, was die PTV-Industrie auch tut, ist, dass sie patchen ihre eigenen Karten und sie reverse-ingenieren die Karten, die die Piraten selber nachgebaut hatte. Und da gibt es sehr viele Geschichten, wie entweder tatsächlich Patches ohne die Karten auszutauschen, also sozusagen ein Update kam over the air, wie man das nennt, also über die Funkstrecke kam ein Update und die Karte hat diese Schwachstelle irgendwie nicht mehr, also durch dieses Update gab es diese Schwachstelle nicht mehr, aber was auch eine sehr große Industrie ist in der PTV-Branche, ist, dass sozusagen Hacker auf Seite des Content-Anbieters bezahlt werden, um Fehler in der Software-Implementierung von den Piratenkarten zu finden, damit sie sozusagen über die Funkstrecke eine Malware, also ein Virus, oder irgendein Exploit, der die Karte ausschaltet, auf die man in bestimmten Zeiten kommt. Und da gab es sehr viele Geschichten, zum Beispiel in den USA hieß es Black Friday oder Black Thursday, ich vergesse immer, wann die Super Bowl gespielt wird, aber jedenfalls war das, oder ne, Sunday müsste das sein, Fußball wird ja immer an Sunday gespielt, aber jedenfalls gab es da so ein schwarzer Tag für die ganzen Leute, die Piraten sind, und dann haben sie tatsächlich fünf Minuten bevor die Super Bowl angefangen hat, hat einer der großen Content-Anbieter sozusagen das letzte Stück von diesem Software, also von diesem Exploit runtergeschickt, so dass alle Piratenkarten ausgeschaltet wurden.
Also eigentlich ökonomisch voll umklugt, das hätte man Samstagnachmittag machen müssen.
Dann hätten nämlich die Leute schnell noch eine neue Karte gekauft.
Okay, da hatten Leute anscheinend viel Spaß. Kehren wir zurück zum Angriff auf den Chip. Also wir haben gerade festgestellt, den Chip kann man von oben sozusagen einmal aufschleifen angucken, dann kann man mit den Nadeln reinstechen und da gibt es den Sicherheitsmechanismen, deswegen geht man jetzt von unten quasi ran.
Genau, also eigentlich sind heutzutage, also alle Mechanismen, die bis heute entwickelt worden sind, gehen eigentlich davon aus, dass der Angreifer von der aktiven Seite des Chips angreift. Das heißt, dass der Angreifer, also wie Starbucks schon sagte, auf der Seite, wo die Transistoren an alle Verbindungen sind.
Nur für unser Verständnis, also ich kenne den Chip so, es gibt eine Leiterplatte, da ist ein Chip drauf und da ist es oben schwarz. Was ist da jetzt oben und unten?
Wir reden von dem Silizium-Ding, was in dem schwarzen Teil drin ist.
Das müsst ihr vielleicht dazu sagen.
Ja, also wenn man eine Intel-Werbung gesehen hat, dann hat man viele Inder gesehen, die da rumlaufen mit großem sogenannten Wafer. Also das sind so große Scheiben, auf denen tatsächlich was glänzt. Ja, und es glänzt nicht gleichmäßig und es glänzt für die menschliche Auge nicht gleichmäßig, weil da tatsächlich irgendwelche Strukturen angebracht worden sind.
Also die Leiterbahnen.
Genau, die Leiterbahnen und die sozusagen darunter sind die Transistoren. Aber was man in der Regel tut, um einen Hype-Leiter zu produzieren, ist, man nimmt eine Seite, ist egal wie, ist ein homogenes Material, sozusagen was man davor hat, also ein gleichmäßiges Material. Und man fängt an, auf einer dieser Seiten sozusagen Material anwachsen zu lassen, indem man das chemisch auf die Oberfläche dampft.
Also diese verschiedenen Schichten.
Also die Leiterbahnen, genau.
Genau, die Leiterbahnen und auch die Wells, um die Transistoren herzustellen.
Und das jetzt ist die Oberseite. Und oben ist, man guckt von oben drauf, also auf die letzte Schicht, die aufgedampft wurde.
Genau, weil das ist auch für die Logik ist die entscheidende, also ist entscheiden, wie die Verbindungen sind. Also schaut man sich eigentlich, in der Regel schaut man sich das Ganze von der Frontside, also von oben an.
Genau, und wenn du sagst, du kommst von unten, dann ist das quasi das Küchenbrett, auf dem das ganze Zeug aufgehört ist? Genau.
Also durch das ganze Silizium erst mal durchgegraben und dann kommt man faktisch von unten an die Transistoren und dann nach die Fahrtratungsleiterbahnen.
Und ich bin eigentlich, sollte ich vielleicht auch erwähnt haben, ich bin auch Doktorand an der TU Berlin bei Herrn Prof. Seifert in Security and Telecommunications. Und meine Doktorarbeit besteht darin, dass wir uns neue Wege ausgedacht haben, wie wir alle Sicherheitsmaßnahmen umgehen können, die heutzutage auf dem Chip sind. Und das Nahliegendste war, wir drehen den Chip um und gehen von der anderen Seite. Weil da gibt es weder diese Schutzschichten, noch die ganzen Sensoren.
Das war wirklich alles. Sie haben einfach nur den Chip umgedreht.
Dafür kriegt man in Deutschland einen Dr. Tieter.
Moment mal. Muss man wirklich gar nichts weiter machen?
Doch, da war ziemlich viel Arbeit darin, wie man die Stelle wiederum, wenn man das Ganze umgedreht hat, wie man die richtige Stelle findet und was man da alles tun kann.
Also Präparierung erst mal, du musst ja erst mal hinkommen, das irgendwie runterpolieren oder runterätzen, runterschleifen.
Genau, also der Rad musste, zwar ist da vieles dabei, aber schon musste irgendwie der Rad neu entwickelt werden, um das zu machen. Also ich will das nicht so sagen, als wenn es so trivial ist, aber ist schon erstaunlich.
Also Dmitry hat seinen Dr. Tieter dann auch wirklich verdient, wenn er ihn hat.
Aber auf der abstrakten Ebene ist es schon so, die clever Idee war, das Ding einfach umzudrehen und dann war die Fleißarbeit sozusagen zu realisieren, wie man das so gemacht hat.
Genau, also die Methoden, die bisher existiert haben, so anzupassen, dass sie auch für die Rückseite funktionieren.
Und natürlich auch neue Methoden zu finden, die halt jetzt durch die Vorderseite nicht mehr gehen.
Genau, also das war alles Thema in meinem Talk. Aber um vielleicht das Ganze so auf den oder in einem Satz zusammenzufassen, eigentlich, was man, man hat sich, wenn man vor allem die Literatur, die wissenschaftliche Literatur dazu anschaut von vor vielen Jahren, haben viele gedacht, dass das alles unmöglich ist. Und das war umso mehr sozusagen, das war erstaunlich, wie einfach das eigentlich ist und was für eine große Bedrohung, das eigentlich für die ganze Industrie ist, weil sie sind darauf völlig unvorbereitet.
Also wie erschreckend ist, es gibt doch tatsächlich nicht wirklich eine Möglichkeit, da jetzt Gegenmaßnahmen zu initialisieren. Also bei der Vorderseite, da gab es halt irgendwie, da macht es halt irgendwie Meshes oder Sensoren. Da kann man sich halt alle möglichen sinnvollen Sachen vorstellen, weil der Rückseite ist halt tatsächlich sehr schwierig, sich auch nur, also wir haben natürlich auch darüber nachgedacht, wie kann man das jetzt irgendwie verhindern, dass wir das tun? Und so richtig coole Ideen hatten wir einfach nicht gehabt.
Um das kurz zusammenzufassen, eigentlich funktioniert der Chip nur, also die Halbleiter, die Chips, werden so hergestellt, dass da tatsächlich nur auf eine Seite sozusagen Material anwächst. Und da gibt es keine Möglichkeit, den Chip umzudrehen und auf der anderen Seite einfach was anwachsen zu lassen. Da gibt es ein paar Ansätze, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das entweder viel zu teuer, weil das den Preis für jeden Chip mehr als verdoppelt, oder das ist einfach nicht realisierbar mit den heutigen Herstellungsmethoden.
Also ich finde ja, wir sollten tatsächlich mal so ein paar Beispiele von diesen Rückseitenangriffen hier mal zu Gute tun. Also ich würde einfach mal, also ich meine, so der Probing haben wir ja schon gesagt, irgendwie das ging halt normalerweise durch die Vorderseite heutzutage. Dann nimmst du halt, also tatsächlich von der Rückseite nimmst halt das ein Fokus einbeam. Also das ist irgendwie so das Gerät, was man als Chip-Hacker heutzutage haben muss.
Das ist ein Fokussiertes Ionenbündel.
Jetzt fühle ich mich wie bei Star Wars.
Das ist auch total Star Wars.
Wie teuer ist sowas?
Das ist ganz schön teuer, also bist du da schon so im Millionen, also so sechsstelligen, siebenstelligen Bereichen zwischen?
Nein, nein, es hängt aber dabei so, ich würde sagen, das hängt schon bei 250.000 an, aber trotzdem ist man...
Der Betrieb selbst ist aber auch ziemlich teuer. Also die Gase und Chemikalien, die man dafür braucht, die sind auch nicht ohne.
Also unabhängig davon, wie teuer die Anschaffungskosten sind, hast du immer die Möglichkeit, für relativ wenig Geld, dir stundenweise oder tageweise dieses Gerät zu leihen. Von daher ist es halt gar nicht so schlimm jetzt, dass es teuer ist. Du kannst halt immer noch mit relativ geringen Kosten diese Angriffe durchführen. Also was man halt tut ist, was wir gerade gesagt haben, man bohrt halt praktisch von hinten durch das Lithium durch, mit diesem Fokuseinbeam, einfach gesprochen, bis man halt an den Transistoren und den Leiterbahnen ist. Und dann kann man sie theoretisch kontaktieren. Das Problem ist halt nun, dass man halt relativ weit gebohrt hat. Das heißt, man muss jetzt irgendwie erst mal diese Leitungen wieder nach draußen verlegen.
Also man muss an dieser Stelle sozusagen vollständig die, also sozusagen von der Gesamtdicke des Chips muss man so circa 98 Prozent entfernen.
Okay, krass.
Also was man tut, man muss halt diese Leiterbahnen irgendwie so weit nach außen wiederbringen, dass man sie dann kontaktieren kann wieder mit den Nadeln. Und dafür, was das Tolle an diesem Fokus einbeben ist, dass es nicht nur Material abtragen kann, sondern auch Material wieder hinzufügen kann. Das heißt, du kannst dann sehr wohl auch Leitendes oder nicht Leitendes Material wieder, also du hast ja dieses Loch, was irgendwie unter auf die Leiterbahn geht und dann schmeißt du halt um ganz viel Wolfram in dieses Loch, also Leitendes Material und füllst es praktisch leitend auf und kannst dann oben auf das Ende vom Loch dann wieder den Nadel setzen und praktisch dem Chip wieder beim Arbeiten.
Also du kannst sozusagen auch diese Verbindung sehr viel, sehr viel größer machen. Also obwohl die sozusagen dieses, dieses Loch, was man durchbohren muss, bis man, bis man an den Transistoren und Leiterbahnen kommt, ankommt, obwohl das sozusagen wirklich in Nanometerbereich sein wird, kann man das wirklich, indem man dann leidfähiges Material abscheidet und eine Verbindung sozusagen nach oben, also in dem Fall weit nach unten zieht, kann man, kann man dann sich diese, also ist es realistisch. Also man kann mit solchen Angriffen tatsächlich auch die neuste Technologien, also die neuste Chips angreifen, die sowas wie 22 Nanometer sind. Man muss nur die passende Gerätschaften dazu haben, die einer dieser Arbeiten möglichen.
Okay, jetzt sagen wir mal, abgesehen von PayTV-Karten, wo ist denn sowas noch interessant?
Die Hüsteltaste. Also zum Beispiel Indikationsdokumente, also E-Pass, E-Perso, da zum Beispiel. Oder Wegversperren, also überall, wo halt mit Sicherheit und Microchips gearbeitet wird, Zugangskarten, also in allen Bereichen.
Okay, würdet ihr sagen, das ist auch auf eine Art und Weise realisierbar, dass man, dass das also jemand, der Interesse daran hat, das wirklich sozusagen für sich auch organisieren kann? Also ihr habt gerade gesagt, irgendwie teures Gret, man kann es aber irgendwie mieten, also ist das jetzt so ein jedermanns Ding oder seid irgendwie Starbucks, Dmitry und Thorsten, genau die drei Leute in Deutschland, die sowas können?
Also es können tatsächlich nicht so wirklich viele, aber wenn jemand Interesse hat, dann kann er schon mit, keine Ahnung, ein bisschen Aufwand, also ein bisschen finanziellen Aufwand beziehungsweise so als Uni, so als Diplomarbeit oder Dissertation auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie ohne Probleme möglich, das zu machen.
Liegt halt an deiner Motivation, was willst du erreichen? Also ich denke, man kann das gar nicht genau sagen, wie viele Leute es eigentlich gibt, die diese Möglichkeit haben, denn ich würde mal vermuten, dass die meisten, die diese Möglichkeit haben, damit nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gehen, weil sie damit nämlich auf dem Schwarzmarkt Geld verdienen am Ende.
Aber was passiert denn zum Beispiel, wenn man, keine Ahnung, so einen Personalausweis dann irgendwie aufmacht und weiß, was da drin ist? Was kann man dann damit machen?
Na du kannst den Key extrahieren, der sicherstellt, dass die Bundesdruckerei diesen Ausweis ausgestellt hat. Das heißt, du kannst dir deinen eigenen Ausweis ausstellen, mit deinen Finger abdrücken, mit deinem Bild und der sieht halt für jedes Lesegerät aus wie ein echter Ausweis. Also er ist offiziell ein echter Ausweis. Und naja, ich meine, heutzutage für Ausweisdokumente in Deutschland zahlt man knappe 10.000 Euro, also gefälschte. Von daher kann man da schon durchaus Geld mitmachen. Und da ist halt auch wieder keine Frage, dass man irgendwie jetzt mal für zwei Tage sich so ein FIP mietet, was dann irgendwie dann 2.000 Euro kostet am Tag, weil du halt mit einem verkauften Dokument das Geld locker wieder drin hast.
Und das Schlimme an diesen Dingern ist ja, dass von allen Stellen, also vom Hersteller, von den Politikern und allen Leuten, die das Ganze befürworten, suggeriert wird, dass alleine durch diesen Chip, diesen Sicherheitschip, der da drin ist, ist dieser Ausweis nicht zu fälschen, nicht zu klonen und macht alles sicherer. Und am Ende, ich meine, am Ende kann man möglicherweise doch diesen Ausweis klonen. Und zwar wird das eben gerade genau dadurch begünstigt, dass da eben Digitaltechnik mit drin steckt, auf die man sich dann eben blind verlässt. Weil alle sagen, man kann sich und muss sich auch blind darauf verlassen.
Das sind einmalige Kosten, von denen wir hier reden. Das machst du einmal, das macht irgendjemand auf der Welt einmal extra diesen Key. Und wenn er diese Informationen freigibt, kann halt jeder Arsch sich einen Ausweis machen.
Ja, also es ist wirklich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, der auf jeden Fall klar rüberkommen muss. Also man hat diese Kosten nur einmal und jeder weitere Ausweis, den man dann vielleicht klonen will, hat halt weniger hohe Kosten zufolge. Das geht dann halt später einfacher.
Das ist dann im Bereich ein paar Tausend Euro.
Na ja, ein paar hundert. Also ich streite gerade über die Aufmachkosten, aber der wichtige Punkt ist, den man als auch wie so ein Nebenbeilern-Effekt, den wir heute hier haben, ist, dass das Problem mit dem E-Perso zum Beispiel ist, es ist in der Tat aufwendiger geworden, so ein Ding zu fälschen, weil ich brauche jetzt für 2000 Euro im Tag einmal so ein Gerät. Aber weil sich die Leute viel mehr drauf verlassen, weil ihnen ja gesagt wurde, das ist ein Chip drin, das ist alles sicher, ist die Fälschungsgefahr eigentlich größer als vorher?
Also der Grenzbeamte guckt jetzt auf die grüne Lampe, die sagt, dieser Chip ist valide, der Ausweis ist damit gültig.
Genau, der Kunde guckt nicht mehr auf das UV-Abstrahl.
Genau, also früher hat der irgendwie angeguckt, ob das Bild übereinstimmt, ob da die ganzen Sicherheitsmerkmale auf dem Pass irgendwie stimmen. Heutzutage ist die grüne Lampe an, alles klar.
Okay, wir haben noch einen Anrufer, der Michael, der hat, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch eine Frage genau zu dem Perso. Hallo Micha.
Ja, naja, gut, dass wir gerade auf das Thema kommen. Als damals der elektronische Personalausweis rauskam, hat der Chaos Computer Club sich damit befasst und gezeigt, dass man diesen RFID-Ship kontaktlos auflesen kann, mit Fingerdrücken ein, um und dran, um den Unfug treiben kann. Und dann könnte man seinen Fingerdruckofen oder Mordswaffe irgendwann wieder finden. Jetzt ist meine Frage, was hat sich da in der Zwischenzeit getan? Ist da was sicherer geworden, beziehungsweise wie kann ich mich gegen das Auslesen schützen?
Also, die Fingerabdrücke konntest du noch nie auslesen. Die sind tatsächlich geschützt mit PKIs, also mit irgendwie kryptographischen Varianten. Wenn du allerdings das, was wir gerade beschrieben haben, diesen Chip einmal irgendwie aufmachst, dann kannst du sehr wohl auch die Fingerabdrücke auslesen. Und dann kannst du diese Fingerabdrücke auch sehr wohl nachbilden und auf eine Mordswaffe platzieren. Aber da gibt es natürlich auch viel einfache Möglichkeiten, um an Fingerabdrücke zu kommen.
Also das ist noch nicht passiert, aber das wäre eine Gefahr.
Den Ausweis selber, ich meine, den hat man ja auch mal in der Haustasse.
Okay, also aber an der Sicherheitsarchitektur hat sich seit Erscheinen des E-Persos nichts geändert.
Also sie haben, glaube ich, inzwischen eine neue Chip-Generation, aber die nicht explizit auf irgendwelche Schwachstellen, also wegen Schwachstellen umgestellt wurde, sondern weil inzwischen schon fast 10 Jahre vergangen sind.
Aber man soll vielleicht an der Stelle auch erwähnen, wie das wirklich funktioniert. Also wenn ein Hersteller eine Chip-Karte ist, dann muss man durch einen staatlichen Zertifizierungsverfahren durch mit seinem Produkt. Also man hat seine Karte, also man hat seinen Chip hergestellt, was in ein E-Perso kommt, und in Deutschland wird das dann vom BSI über ein sogenanntes Common Criteria Verfahren zertifiziert. Und was auch zeigt für mich, wie kaputt Zertifizierung an sich ist, ist, dass einer der Kriterien ist, damit eine Karte zertifiziert bleibt, ist, dass keine Angriffe gegen diese Karte bekannt sind. Das heißt, wenn der Hersteller versehentlich diese Karte, also diese Chip, die im Perso ist, auch bei Druckerpatronen oder bei TPMs oder TPTV hatte, und plötzlich ist da ein Angriff bekannt geworden, kann der Angreifer plötzlich oder verliert der Hersteller diese Karte seine Zertifizierung und darf nicht mehr in deutsche Personalausweise integriert werden.
Also das ist unter anderem ein Grund, dass wir nicht nur einen Chiphersteller für die Personalausweise und Pässe haben, sondern zwei. Das heißt, wenn einer irgendwie ausfällt oder gehackt wird, dass man immer noch sagen kann, dann schenken wir jetzt mal schnell auf den anderen um für die nächsten 10.000 Personalausweise.
Micha, hat das deine Frage beantwortet?
Ja, du kannst die Daten aus, also du kannst zum Beispiel das Gesichtsbild auslesen, wenn du halt die Maschinedisparation hast. Also der Schlüssel für das Aussehen des Gesichtsbildes ist irgendwie auf dem E-Perso und der E-Pass aufgedruckt. Aber um halt die Fingerabdruckbilder auszulesen, brauchst du tatsächlich Zertifikate, die nur Grenzbeamte und Meldestellenbeamte haben. Also da kommst du nicht so einfach ran.
Okay, vielleicht können wir noch ein bisschen allgemein draufkommen, wie ich mich so gegen Hardware-Hacks und so ein bisschen schützen kann.
Das hat sich bis jetzt glaube ich viel schwierig angehört, aber vielleicht kann man dazu gleich noch ein Wort verlieren. Micha, vielen Dank für die Frage. Und viel Spaß noch. So, dann machen wir jetzt wie gesagt erstmal die Nachrichten. Und dann in der letzten halben Stunde beschäftigen wir uns noch ein bisschen mit den sogenannten Seitenkanal-Attacken. Aber dazu dann gleich mehr.
Hey Mann, unter den ganz großen Shootingstars ist John Newman noch relativ neu, Mann.
Ritz präsentiert.
Mittwoch, 5. März. Schon echt groß, aber immer noch neu, man.
John Newman präsentiert von.
Die Ukraine hat den Internationalen Währungsfonds offiziell um Hilfe gebeten. Angeblich steht das Land kurz vor dem Mangrot. Der Finanzbedarf für die kommenden Jahre wird auf umgerechnet 35 Milliarden Euro geschätzt. Der gestürzte Präsident Janukovic will sich laut Medienberichten morgen auf einer Pressekonferenz äußern. Er hält sich offenbar in Russland auf. Bereits heute erklärte er, dass er seine Absetzung nicht akzeptiert. Der Prozess gegen den ehemaligen Bundespräsidenten Wolf und den mit angeklagten Filmproduzenten Gronewald ist mit Freisprüchen zu Ende gegangen. Das Gericht erklärt in seiner Urteilsbegründung, ein strafbares Verhalten habe beiden nicht nachgewiesen werden können. Wolf sagte, das Recht habe sich durchgesetzt. Laut Anklage hatte er sich bei möglichen Sponsoren für ein Filmprojekt eingesetzt, weil Gronewald einen Oktoberfestbesuch von Wolf zum Teil bezahlt hatte. Die Staatsanwaltschaft will in der kommenden Woche entscheiden, ob sie Revisionen einlegt. Nutzer des Internetkonzerns Yahoo! sind offenbar jahrelang vom britischen Geheimdienst GCHQ ausspieniert worden. Der Guardian berichtet, dass zwischen 2008 und 2010 wahllos Standbilder von Videochats mit der Webcam gespeichert wurden. Betroffen seien etwa 1, 8 Millionen Nutzer. Der Geheimdienst habe danach versucht, die Personen per Gesichtserkennung zu identifizieren. Das stehen Unterlagen des Informanten Snowden. Eintracht Frankfurt ist in der Zwischenrunde der Fußball Europa League ausgeschieden. Gegen den FC Porto spielten die Hessen 3 zu 3 unentschieden. Aufgrund des Hinspiels ist Frankfurt damit aber trotzdem draußen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Hellersdorf 3 und in Rheiningen-Dorf 8 Grad. Neuglobso 4, Bad Freienwalde 5, Cottbus 6 und Potsnam 7 Grad. In der Nacht ist es überall ziemlich wolkig, Regen ist aber die Ausnahme. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 4 bis plus 1 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wolkig, später lockert es etwas auf bei 8 bis 11 Grad. Mit einer Meldung in Berlin, Tunneltiergarten, ist bis Reich-Peach-Ufer zwischen Invalidenstraße und George C. Marshall Brücke nach einem Unfall gesperrt. Ansonsten rollt es euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit.
Naja, eine halbe haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um Hardware-Hacking geht. Wir haben schon viel gelernt über Chips aufschleifen, zum Beispiel in der letzten halben Stunde. Ihr könnt den Podcast auch nachhören, wenn euch das alles interessiert. Gibt es diese Nacht noch auf fritz.de, ansonsten auch auf chaosradio.ttc.de. So, zu Gast sind zum Beispiel Thorsten, Dimitri und Starbucks, der gerade unter dem Tisch verschwunden ist. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was da los ist. Ich würde jetzt gerne zu dem Punkt kommen, was wird denn hier gelacht? Es gibt da zu lachen. Die Rolls-Royce-Bataste. Den wir am Anfang schon mal kurz angesprochen hatten, die sogenannten Seitenkanal-Attacken. Was genau heißt es eigentlich?
Also für Leute, die überhaupt in Hardware-Hacking einsteigen wollen, sind Seitenkanal-Angriffe ein sehr interessanter und zugänglicher, weil man dafür nicht so viele Gerätschaften braucht, wie wir in der Sendung erwähnt haben.
Also Seitenkanal-Angriffe. Normalerweise tut Chip irgendwas, um seine cryptografischen Funktionen durchzuführen. Dabei tut er noch was anderes, was man von außen angucken kann. Er verbraucht Strom und anhand dieses Stromverbrauchs kann man ermitteln, was er tatsächlich intern tut.
Also das heißt, man beobachtet Dinge, die jetzt gar nichts direkt mit dem Betrieb von Software zu tun haben.
Genau, Seiteneffekte, die man ausnutzt. Randeffekte, um dann zu schließen auf das, was da gerade passiert ist.
Und da gibt es die diversen, zum Beispiel magnetische Strahlung, elektromagnetische Strahlung oder den Stromverbrauch oder Photonaussendung. Also ich finde da tatsächlich Photonaussendung eines der coolsten Beispiele und da sind wir auch gleich wieder bei der Rückseite.
Bei der Rückseite vom Chip, über die wir schon gesprochen haben?
Genau, das ist einer der Angriffe, die Dmitry auch in seiner Deskortation beschreiben wird oder beschreibt. Also Seitenkanäle. Dieser Chip tut ja was, er hat da Transistoren, die ihn hin und her schalten, um den Programmcode auszuführen. Nun ist es so, dass so ein Transistor, wenn er schaltet, in ganz geringem Maße auch Photonen aussendet. Das heißt, wieder flitzen Elektronen rum, die zur Funktion des Transistors beitragen und ab und zu wird so ein Elektron in so ein Photon umgewandelt. Das heißt Licht. Ein Lichtteilchenwelle, du alles musst. Was man jetzt tun kann, ist, man guckt durch die Rückseite diesen Transistoren zu, wie sie praktisch arbeiten. Das heißt, du hast dort eine Kamera, die relativ...
Günstig ist. Na doch, wir haben das auch mit Kameras gemacht, die empfindlich ist.
Also die halt tatsächlich so einzelne Photonen mehr oder weniger aufnehmen kann.
Reden wir da wieder von einem halben Millionen Dollar Gerät?
Nö, wir sind da auf jeden Fall im wenigen 1000 Euro Bereich.
3000 bis 5000 Euro. Also was man eigentlich in der Regel tut, wenn man wirklich solche Seidenkanne-Angriffe machen möchte, ist, man kauft aus dem Astronomie-Bereich einer Kamera und die passende Mikroskop-Optik dazu. Also das Gewinde ist standardisiert, also kann man auch ein Mikroskop-Objektiv da dran schrauben. Und Astronomie ist so populär, dass man billig Infrarot-Kameras kaufen kann.
Das haben wir noch nicht dazu gesagt, also das geht halt in dem Fall um Infrarot-Licht, dass man sich anguckt und deswegen ist es auch ganz toll, dass man sich durch die Rückseite anguckt, weil Silizium, also das Triggermaterial für Infrarot-Licht durchsichtig ist. Das heißt, man sieht halt tatsächlich von hinten diesen Transistoren. Also das ist halt der Sinn von diesen Seitenkanälen, dass du halt die aktive, also die normale Funktion dieses Transistors ist, dass er irgendwie schaltet, blablabla. Und zusätzlich macht er halt ab und zu mal noch was anderes. Und das andere, was er tut, ist halt dieses Photon-Aussenden, womit man dann halt im Endeffekt tatsächlich Schaltvorgänge sichtbar machen kann. Also das heißt, du kannst tatsächlich sagen, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, zu welchen Transistoren gerade geschaltet haben oder welcher Speicherbereich gerade ausgelesen wurde. Und wenn man das tun kann, dann hat man natürlich ein Feld von Informationen, womit man sozusagen den gesamten Chip mehr oder weniger blank vor sich liegen hat. Also dass man ihm alles extrahieren kann.
Und dann muss man so sagen, muss man gar nichts mehr reinstecken, aufschneiden, sondern man macht einfach nur das Licht aus und die Kamera an.
Im Endeffekt ist das genau so, ja.
Das ist ja großartig. Gibt es noch mehr? Das hört sich nach einem spannenden Bereich an. Also ich habe zum Beispiel, oder andersrum, Frage. Ich habe neulich gehört, man kann Chips dabei zuhören, wie sie Kryptografie entschlüsseln.
Genau.
Und zwar indem man ein Handy daneben legt.
Genau. Also das wurde auch letztens gezeigt, dass es tatsächlich machbar ist. Also es gibt tatsächlich, abhängig von der Berechnung, die gerade auf dem Chip stattfindet, kann man von der, von, man kennt auch dieses Effekt mit dem, mit, wenn ein Handy klingelt, hört man plötzlich durch die Autolautsprecher, wie das Handy klingelt. Also gibt es Frequenzen, die irgendwie auch im hörbaren Bereich sind. Und genauso ist das auch mit der Kryptographie teilweise. Da wird auch ein sehr geringer Teil sozusagen von den Frequenzen, abhängig von der Berechnung, hört man auch. Und das heißt, wenn man, je nachdem, was man für Frequenzen hört und von der Amplitude, also von der Stärke, von der Lautstärke der Frequenzen, kann man tatsächlich die einzelnen Nullen zurückrechnen. Also Dmitry praktisch die Schlüssel. Genau, in den Fällen, man sollte das auch erwähnen, das ist auch ein Grund, warum man heutzutage Kryptographie in hohen Sicherheitssystemen, in Hardware tatsächlich realisiert, weil man da solche Problematiken viel besser unter Kontrolle hat, wenn man sie tatsächlich als Transistoren realisiert und nicht mehr als Software.
Also wir wollten ja coole Beispiele bringen, die irgendwie für Seitenkanäle, wo man jetzt mal ein bisschen vom Chip weggeht und so ein bisschen anschaulicher und greifbarer hat, eine Tastatur. Eine Tastatur dient dazu, irgendwie deinen Key einzutippen, irgendwie deiner Freundin zu schreiben und was auch immer. Was die Tastatur tut, ist sie sendet auch Geräusche aus, wenn du auf den Tasten rauf rumhaust. Was es jetzt als Seitenkanal gibt oder als Seitenkanal Angriff gibt, du hast ein Telefon, dich ruft jemand an, du legst irgendwie dein Handy oder dein Hörer neben das Telefon, redest mit ihm, während du tippst. Er sagt dir, gib mal dein Passwort ein, tippst dein Passwort auf die Tastatur ein. Die Tastaturanschläge selber verraten dem am anderen Ende des Telefons sitzenden, welche Tasten du gerade gedrückt hast. Weil halt jede Taste ein bisschen anders klingt, wenn man sie drückt. Das ist halt so ein klassischer Seitenkanal über Audio, wo man halt tatsächlich so ganz einfache Sachen extrahieren kann, wie ein Passwort.
Um das Beispiel weiterzuführen, es gab auch ein sehr schönes Paper, dass jeder Smartphone heutzutage ein Gyroskop drauf hat. Und je nachdem, wie das gerade in der Hand liegt, und wie man auf der Tastatur, die auf dem Bildschirm ist, draufdrückt, kann man anhand der Beschleunigung, also der Bewegung, wie man sozusagen auf dem Handy getippt hat und wie es sich ein bisschen verdreht hat, weil man mit dem Finger aufgedrückt hat, auch die Tastendrücke, also die Tasteneingaben auf dem Bildschirm zurückrechnen. Aber da gibt es jede Menge Beispiele. Also vielleicht das anschaulichste und einfachste ist ein sogenanntes Timing-basiertes Seitenkanal-Angriff, der, bin ich mir sicher, auch in vielen Geräten noch zu finden sein wird, die Leute um sich herumliegen haben, nämlich die Pin-Eingabe. Und oft ist es so, dass wenn man, also wenn man selber viele, also viel programmiert hat, kennt man das, dass wenn man das sozusagen in den Code schreibt, wird man nach jedem Tastendruck, wird man sozusagen, wird das Programm schauen, ob das gestimmt hat oder nicht. Und man kann tatsächlich ausmessen, wie schnell das Programm reagiert hatte und daraus zurückrechnen, ob das gerade eine gültige oder ungültige Ziffer-Eingabe war.
Sind wir dann noch wie beim Geldautomaten, ich drücke eine Ziffer, also ich gebe meine PIN-Nummer an, und je nachdem, wie schnell der piep kommt, weiß ich dann im Prinzip schon, ob es gerade richtig oder falsch war. Und dann kann ich sozusagen anfangen, die PIN-Nummer zu raten. Und vorhin habe ich ja schon gelernt, wenn ich den Stromzufuhr des Geldautomaten kontrolliere, kann ich dann auch verhindern, dass der Sperr nicht so oft falsch gerannt ist.
Stark vereinfacht dargestellt.
Klar, stark vereinfacht dargestellt, aber dann braucht man nicht mehr so viele Versuche, weil ich meine, es gibt nur zehn Ziffern und die erste habe ich dann relativ schnell raus.
Und dann die zweite und dann die vierte. Also wenn du es halt nicht mehr zehntausendmalst versuchen, sondern tatsächlich dann pro Stelle zehnmal.
Da wäre übrigens eine Gegenmaßnahme, die auch tatsächlich angewandt wird von den Programmierern dieser Software in diesen Chips, dass man eben auch zufällige Delays einbaut zwischen verschiedenen Tastendrücken.
Also das wäre halt eine mögliche Maßnahme, um so eine zeitbasierten Side-Channel-Angriffe oder tatsächlich erst mal komplett die vierstellige Pinneneingabe abwartet und dann halt diese gesamte Vierstelligzahl einmal vergleicht und nicht halt jede Ziffer einzeln.
Am Ende ist das wieder irgendwie ein Programmierfehler, also nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Genau, wir kommen doch nicht von der Software ganz weg.
Ärgerlich.
Jetzt gibt es hier noch in der Liste von Dingen, die für mich interessant klingen, den Stichpunkt Sensoren täuschen.
Also für mich, ich dachte, das würde für mich in die Kategorie fallen. Ich glaube, zumindest so wie ich Sensoren verstanden habe, waren das auch die Angriffssensoren, die wir als Gegenmaßnahmen erwähnt haben. Aber ich meine, nur um dieses Beispiel ein bisschen nochmal vielleicht anders darzustellen, ist eigentlich auch das, was Thorsten vorhin sagte. Es geht auch, dass man auf einem Chip oder in einem Sicherheitssystem oder auf einem, sagen wir mal, nehmen wir mal an, man hat sowas wie ein iPhone, wo mittlerweile ein Fingerprint-Sensor ist. Man weiß ja nicht, von wo der Signal, also Apple sagt einem ja nicht, von wo der Signal ausgesendet wird, dass der Fingerabdruck anerkannt wurde. Es kann durchaus sein, dass das an irgendeiner Stelle passiert, sogar auf dem PCB vom iPhone, also auf der Platine, wo die ganzen Chips zusammenverdrahtet sind, dass man da sozusagen einen gültigen Fingerprint gegebenenfalls vortäuschen kann. Ich glaube nicht, dass Apple so gravierende Fehler gemacht hat, aber dieser Fehler mit den Zertifikaten war doch ziemlich schlecht.
Du meinst halt, um jetzt ausgeschaltet... Um es noch mal vereinfachter zu stellen, praktisch hinter der Vergleich ist der aktuelle Fingerabdruck mit dem der Datenbank gleich, dann ist ja irgendwie die Abfrage ja oder nein, dass man dahinter dieses eine Bit dann irgendwie umändert.
Okay, dann haben wir noch Sicherheit, die Sicherungen löschen, Fuses, das fand ich ganz gut, weil Sicherung kenne ich halt von zu Hause, wenn im Bad das Licht ausgeht, dann...
Stand da wirklich Sicherung in der Liste?
Es steht Fuses, das sind halt so Schutzmechanismen von Mikrocontrollern, die verhindern sollen, dass man bestimmte Daten aus so einem Chip oder aus dem Speicher wieder auslesen kann. Also wer sich mal mit Mikrocontrollern ein bisschen befasst hat, der weiß, dass man mit Programmieradaptern oder sonst was für Mechanismen eben seine programmierte Firmware in diesen Mikrocontroller reinflaschen kann. Also man speichert diesen Binaerkod auf diesem Chip und man kann ihn auch wieder auslesen. Und durch diese Fuses, also diese Sicherungen, kann man diesen Chip nochmal auf einem Niveau konfigurieren und Sicherheitsmaßnahmen aktivieren, die zum Beispiel verhindern, dass man diesen Code wieder auslesen kann. Weil wir wissen ja, dass Hacker, die irgendwelche Geräte und Gadgets, die sich anschauen wollen, die wollen vor allen Dingen versuchen, an diese Firmware zu kommen, also an diese Binary Files. Und dafür setzt man dann eben diese Fuses, dass es auf dem einfachen Wege eben nicht möglich ist. Das heißt, man muss dann eben schon wieder einen sehr viel höheren Aufwand betreiben, um diesen Schutzmechanismus noch auszuhebeln oder zu umgehen. Und da gibt es eben auch entsprechend Möglichkeiten, diese Fuses neu zu konfigurieren. Und da gibt es halt ja, das können halt Implementierungsfehler sein in der Logik, dass man vielleicht den Chip selber nicht mal kaputt machen muss oder aufmachen muss, um dann dort, was ich, mit bestimmtem Licht auch noch reinzuleuchten. Aber eben Hardware-seitige Angriffe gegen diese Chips, um halt einmalig an diese Firmware ranzukommen. Da gibt es halt einige Mechanismen, die sich ja Dmitry auch besser beschreiben kann, weil er das halt häufiger tut.
Also bei der Hardware kann man sagen, mit einem FIP geht das auf jeden Fall immer. Also du kannst einfach mit so einem FIP alles machen und dann so einen Kanon auf den Spatzen schießen.
Bei Fuses finde ich auch sehr interessant oder ist ein interessantes Beispiel dafür, dass auch viele, also Fuses sind in der Regel etwas, wo du vom Werk aus einmalig, also es gibt auch Fuses, wo man sie mehrmals überschreiben kann, aber es gibt auch einmalige Fuses und einmalige Fuses werden oft benutzt, um beispielsweise pro Karte einen anderen Schlüssel zu speichern. Also in der PTV-Karte zum Beispiel ist es oft so, dass der Schlüssel, der diese Karte eigentlich enthält, in Fuses gespeichert wird. Und genauso bei Xbox oder Wii und sonst was.
Also ein einmalig Schreiben heißt in dem Fall, dass sie durch hohen Strom anlegen, die Sicherung durchbrennen lassen. Also wie eine normale Sicherung, da wird einfach Strom angelegt, dann ist es durchgebrannt, das repräsentiert dann eine Null, wenn es nicht durchgebrannt ist, ist es eine Eins.
Und was man dann tun kann, ist, wenn man diese Stelle identifiziert hat auf dem Chip, kann man tatsächlich auch mit einer Probing-Nadel dahin gehen und den Ausgang des Fuses, also wo die Logik, wo die Eins oder Null aus diesem Fus rausfällt, kann man sie treiben. Und man kann zum Beispiel, indem man einen hohen Strom anlegt, also nicht einen hohen Strom, sondern eine Versorgungsspannung, also eine Eins legt man an, kann man dafür sorgen, also man weiß ja, man treibt immer, man ist immer als Angreifer stärker als die Karte selber und man weiß, dass da auf der Schaltung eine Eins vorliegt, wenn man mit der Probing-Nadel da drauf sitzt. Das heißt, man kann dann alle Bits, also alle Schlüssel-Bits des alle Fuses durchgehen und da einfach mal sagen, jetzt will ich, dass du eine Eins treibst. Und was man dabei tut, ist, man schaut, also wo wir jetzt zurück bei, also wo wir wieder bei Seitenkanoneingriffen sind, man guckt, ob der, ob die Nachricht, die man aus der Karte bekommt, sich verändert hat. Weil wenn sie sich verändert hat, weiß man, dass ein Bild gekippt ist. Und da man weiß, dass das Bild auf eins gesetzt worden ist, wenn es sich gekippt hat, weiß man, dass es eine Null vorher hat.
So kann man das sagen, dann langsam rausfinden. Jetzt wissen wir, was man alles machen kann, das ist durchaus spannend. Und ich weiß, ob es jetzt nur, also klar, es gibt diese, also Druckerpatronen kann man täuschen für Autos, vielleicht interessant. Aber die großen Sachen sind, also Pay-TV, da ist es ganz wichtig und beim E-Pay, sozusagen ein politisches Ding, kann man sagen. Ist Hardware-Hacking jetzt eher so eine spannende Kategorie, weil es da so viel zu erleben gibt, wenn man sie erstmal beschäftigt, oder ist das tatsächlich in unserem persönlichen Alltag wird das auch irgendwie wichtig? Oder wie Michael es gefragt hat, kann man sich vor sowas überhaupt schützen? Oder muss man sich überhaupt vor sowas schützen? Oder bin ich als normaler User eigentlich eher das Ziel von Softwareangriffen?
Also was man vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang sagen muss, wenn es halt eine Schwäche in der Software gibt, dann kann man ein Update anspielen. Das heißt, wie bei Apple jetzt gerade, wartet man halt ein paar Tage, klickt dann auf Update. Oder ein paar Tage länger.
Oder anderthalb Jahre.
Klickt dann auf Update und dann ist das Problem gelöst. Bei Hardware ist es halt nicht so einfach zu machen. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, ich verdrate jetzt die Transistoren neu. In der Regel ist bei Hardware so, dass du dann tatsächlich den kompletten Chip oder das komplette System tatsächlich auswechseln musst.
In PTV sieht es so aus, dass man tatsächlich eine neue Karte bekommt von seinem PTV-Anbieter. Also wenn sie rausfinden, dass es kopierte Karten im Umlauf sind, wenn sie abschätzen, wie viele Karten das tatsächlich sind und wenn es zu viele sind, dass sie viel zu große Verluste dadurch machen, schicken sie einfach jedem, der tatsächlich sein Fernsehen bezahlt, eine neue Karte, die dann wiederum diese Schwachstelle nicht mehr hat.
Und das zeigt einfach mal, um wie viel das Geld da geht. Also ich meine, so eine Karte kostet halt schon so ein paar Euro, irgendwie 5, 6 Euro oder so was und mal 100.000 oder ein paar Millionen irgendwie Zuschauer. Das heißt, da ist schon einfach mal echt viel Geld zu machen, sowohl für die Piraten als auch Geld zu verlieren für die Hersteller.
Also ich halte fest, woanders spielt das anscheinend keine große Rolle in unserem alltäglichen Leben.
Na also P-TV ist auf jeden Fall tatsächlich so das Treiben, da ist am meisten passiert in der Vergangenheit.
Also für mich ist das einfach, wo die Gewinne, die sich die Piraten in dem Sinne aus P-TV rausschlagen können, sind am größten. Also heutzutage, würde ich sagen, wenn man das mit den Druckerpatronen beobachtet, ist es interessant zu sehen, dass es auch in anderen Gebieten so weitergeht.
Also ich denke mal, wegversperre ist irgendwie das zweite Beispiel.
Ich denke, das ist halt auch irgendwie so ein Markt, wo so ein Research am Ende auch durch Produktverkauf wieder zurückfinanziert wird. Also dass eben Leute sich die ganzen Krypto-Algorithmen in den Autoschlüsseln anschauen und wie man diese Wegfahrsperren umgehen kann. Und sowas wird dann am Ende auf dem Schwarzmarkt verkauft, sodass eben irgendwelche Autodiebe das leichter haben, diese Autos aufzumachen und schnell aufzumachen, ohne dass Alarm ausgelöst wird und so weiter. Also ich denke, das ist halt auch nochmal so ein, das wird bestimmt in Zukunft, wird uns das häufiger begegnen, dass uns diese ganzen elektronischen Geräte, auf die wir uns verlassen müssen, nochmal auf die Füße fallen. Also da, wo wirklich auch Geld dann eine Rolle spielt. Autos, Pay-TV, das wird immer so bleiben. Identitätsdiebstahl ist irgendwie eines der größten Probleme, mit denen im Internet halt auch zu kämpfen ist. Und das wird natürlich begünstigt dadurch, wenn wir irgendwann mal Schwachstellen in unseren Personalausweisen finden, die sich eben ausnutzen lassen, um die Dinger zu klonen, um die Identität zu stehlen. Ja, das ist halt noch nicht so besonders akut, aber ich denke, das kann man schon so sagen.
Aber Markus hat das Beispiel mit Autoersatzteilen sehr gut gefallen.
Überall da, wo die Hersteller vor allem durch Lizenzierungsgebühren auch Geld verdienen. Das ist bei den Druckerpatronen halt so. Das ist ja nicht, dass diese Patrone 80 Euro kostet, weil das Zeug so teuer ist, sondern weil das ist halt so... Die verkaufen billige Drucker und wollen mit den Druckerpatronen nachher das Geld machen. Und bei Autos wird das auch so sein. Das heißt, die einzelnen Komponenten, die in so einem modernen Auto verbaut werden, die authentifizieren sich so gegeneinander, dass sie ja so sicher sein können, ich spreche jetzt hier wirklich mit einem Bauteil von Hersteller XY und alles andere wird halt verworfen. Also das wird dann nicht akzeptiert, sodass man eben immer Originalersatzteile kaufen muss.
Also das ist zu sagen, das ist...
Kundenbindung.
Das ist Kopierschutz für Dinge.
Genau.
Und sagen die Software-Piraten, also die Hardware-Piraten sozusagen, sind dann die Leute, die Hardware-Hacking machen, um diese Authentifizierung von Dingen zu umgehen.
Genau. Und dann gibt es Leute, die gehen damit dann an den CCC-Kongress und machen einen lustigen Talk drüber. Und dann gibt es auch Leute, die gehen damit nach China und bauen eben Geräte, die das Ganze dann...
Originalteile. Kaufen sie Originalteile. Hardware-Hacking war das. Sehr spannend, sehr interessant. Vielen Dank an Starbucks, Dmitry und Thorsten, die sich da zwei Stunden Zeit genommen haben, um das zu erklären. Ihr könnt diese Sendung auch noch mal nachhören. In allen Details auf fritz.de wird der Podcast heute Nacht erscheinen, im Laufe der Woche sicherlich auch unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Und zum Schluss gibt es noch ein paar Termine und News, die die Herren euch mitteilen wollen. Bitte schön, bitte schön.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Liste... Ich hab hier zwei Termine, auf die ich noch hinweisen wollte, weil die halt in der nächsten Zeit anstehen.
Über das 30C3 wurde schon mal gesprochen in der letzten Sendung, oder? Aber jetzt sind auf jeden Fall alle Videos im Internet. Die sollte man sich alle anfangen.
Stimmt, ich muss noch Videos gucken.
Wenn ihr z.B. den Talk von Dmitry sehen wollt, der genau über dieses Ding noch mal in ganzer Sprache hat, das kann man sich z.B. antun. Und es gibt auf der Website jetzt alle Talks in allen, nicht in allen Sprachen, aber sozusagen in Bild und Ton. Was waren die noch, die beiden Termine?
Wir haben im Ostern natürlich wieder die Easter Hack. Die findet vom 18. bis zum 21. April in Stuttgart statt. Und da kann man sich ja jetzt schon mal langsam bemühen, sich die Reise und was ich etwaige vorträge, die man vortragen möchte, vorzubereiten.
Was ist Easter Hack ganz kurz?
Das ist eine kleine Veranstaltung.
Das ist der Deckung Rest in Klein. Also sehr gemütlich, ein paar hundert Leute, nette Lokalität.
Aber ein Stück.
Und die Camping-Fanatiker unter euch freuen sich sicherlich über das Camp++, das im letzten Jahr unter dem Namen Camp Zero stattfand, und zwar in Ungarn. Das ist zwar noch eine Weile hin, das findet vom 21.8. bis 24.8. im Fort Monostor in Komarom Ungarn statt. Und das erwähne ich vor allen Dingen deshalb, weil dort auch noch eine Submission Deadline für Talks besteht, die dann am 1.4. abläuft. Das heißt, wer gerne auf einem sehr gemütlichen Camp auch mal etwas vortragen möchte, der sollte sich das mal anschauen.
In Englisch aber wahrscheinlich dann.
Ich denke schon. Ich könnte die URL jetzt vorlesen. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht pack ich die einfach in den IRC für das Protokoll, oder?
Genau, das können wir auch in den Blogpost zur Sendung machen, zur nächsten.
Ich habe mir das heute mal erklären und zeigen lassen. Und das sieht schon nach einem wirklich netten Event aus. Also zumindest auch die Umgebung macht einen sehr netten Eindruck.
Also im Sommer mal draußen sitzen und trotzdem hacken.
Gibt es da auch Internet?
Ich vermute.
Fahrt hin und findet es selber raus. Liebe Leute, liebe Kinder, lieber Hörerinnen, das war das Chaosradio Nummer 198. Wir übergehen an dieser Stelle an Flo Heiler, der euch im Night Flight. Ich vermute, es wird Musik, in der Stromgitarren vorkommen sein. Nur so eine Vermutung. Woher weißt du das? Unglaublich. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich verabschiede mich und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.